Jetzt drücke ich hier erst mal die Taste.
Drück mal die Taste.
Und das heißt, dass die Sendung angefangen hat. Ja, wir kommen hier im Kanal, wir nehmen direkt Zugang zum Internet, denn wir sind live, haben aber heute mal aufgrund irgendwelcher Verpeilungen meinerseits oder auch Änderungen in der Webseite bei Xenim. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob ich jetzt nur in die falsche Stelle gucke oder ob es ja was getan hat. Keine Ahnung, wie viele uns zuhören, aber es sind mindestens drei. Wie? Drei, die bisher zugegeben haben, dass sie im Chat sind und sich geoutet haben als Mobamex-Hörer. Man hat ja noch nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, sich zu outen. Also bei Bits und so geht das jetzt los. Die laufen jetzt alles mit T-Shirts rum. Sie haben ihre Agenten jetzt überall. Ich hatte jetzt auch Hörer-Treffen in Frankfurt und da war dann auch schon eins. Es gibt ein Mobamex-T-Shirt? Nein, es gibt ein Bits und so-T-Shirt. Ist ja gar nichts mit.
Bits und so-T-Shirt. Kann man machen.
Kann man machen. Aber wir haben noch keins.
Wir sollten mal welche machen, dass das nicht so schwer ist.
Meinst du, ich bin ja mit unserem Logo nicht so glücklich?
Nee, so richtig super ist es nicht.
Ich bin auch mit unserem Namen nicht so richtig glücklich.
Aber es ist die Myriad in unserem Logo.
Du meinst, wir sind so Apple-y, wie es nur irgendwie geht? Ich meine, wenn wir oldschool wären, hätten wir Apple-Garamond genommen.
Genau.
Und zwar nicht ITC-Garamond, sondern Apple-Garamond.
Ich kann ja mal erzählen, also das Logo, wie es aussieht, das hat Johnny Häusler irgendwann mal gemacht.
Ja, der Johnny Häusler.
Nein, nein, ich wollte es nur sagen, was lustig daran war, hat er mir irgendwann das Republika-Logo 2007, was auch er gemacht hat, gezeigt und meinte, irgendwoher kommt mir das bekannt vor, habe ich das irgendwo kopiert? Weil dieser Schwung, der da oben dran ist, der war am ersten Republika-Logo auch dran.
Johnny hat übrigens auch das Chaos-Radio-Logo als erster geskribbelt, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Ja, genau, das hat er immer so hingefummelt.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, also es ist ein bisschen chaotisch. Ich habe es dann so über die Jahre immer mal wieder so in meiner jeweils aktuellen Vector-Bearbeitungssoftware mir vor die Lupe genommen und dann das sozusagen mal so ein bisschen mehr weitergebracht. Aber so richtig entwickelt hat sich das eigentlich noch nie. Ach, können wir nochmal hier den Vorhang zunehmen? Mal gucken, ob das gerade so weit reicht. Ich denke, das sollte gehen. So, das ist jetzt der Vorhang, hinter dem wir die...
Die iPads wieder verstecken.
Die unangenehmen Informationen verstecken. Da ziehen wir einfach den Vorhang drüber hinweg. So, also jetzt nochmal richtige Ansage hier. Willkommen bei Mobile Max. Vielleicht fangen wir auch mit dem internen Kram ein bisschen an, bevor wir freimütig zugeben, dass wir eigentlich keine richtigen Themen haben und uns eh hier nur was einfallen lassen müssen. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir schon durch die ganze Terminverpeilung, die wir hier haben.
Haben wir drei Wochen?
Jetzt sind wir eigentlich in so einen Drei-Wochen-Modus gegangen, aber die Nachrichtenlage verdichtet sich nicht nennenswert. Nicht, dass wir jetzt immer nur auf der Nachrichtenlage hopfen, aber hüpfen, hopfen, hopfen, herumhüpfen. Trotzdem hat sich einfach noch nicht so sehr viel ergeben. Alle Leute warten irgendwie auf das iPad. Ich auch. Keiner ist bereit, irgendwas anderes zu tun. Apple will auch noch keine neue MacBooks vorstellen und so weiter. Das ist alles ganz edel. Ich denke, sie werden sich jetzt auch noch Zeit lassen mit den MacBooks.
Meinst du?
Ja, dass jetzt erstmal der iPad-Hype vollkommen anfiltert dahergeht.
Werden diese Core 2 Duo, die Apple im Augenblick verbaut, überhaupt noch produziert?
Die werden bestimmt noch produziert.
Ja klar, aber...
Ich glaube nicht, dass die jetzt so...
Ja. Du wolltest erst mal in deinem Leben werden. Ich wollte jetzt nicht vom Thema ablenken.
Du wolltest nicht vom Thema ablenken? Das ist doch auch schon mal sehr schön. Das ist ja mal ganz was Neues. Ja, also unsere Termine sind ein bisschen durcheinander. Was war noch intern anzukündigen? Na ja, wir haben halt... Also es kann durchaus sein, dass wir jetzt häufiger noch mal so einen Dreiewochentakt senden. Es ist einfach alles gerade ein bisschen knifflig. So alle sind irgendwie 9to5, außer... Na ich auch, aber ich bin halt der Einzige, der 9to5 podcastet. Wir machen 9to5 keine Podcasts. Das widerspricht sich natürlich alles so ein bisschen. Und der Samstag ist aber auch schwierig zu opfern. Aber heute ging das auf jeden Fall. Ansonsten gibt es nur so die üblichen Probleme mit der Bandbreite des...
Ach, gibt es da Probleme?...
des Servers. Ja, naja. Die Situation ist eigentlich nach wie vor unverändert. Und ich bin es auch schon so ein bisschen light, das Thema. Aber die Peak-Nachfrage am Anfang nach der Veröffentlichung ist halt einfach zu hoch. Es ist so. Also kann es auch nicht ändern, aber es laden einfach so viele Leute von diesem Server ihre Daten runter, dass der eben derzeit mit seiner schwachpustigen 100-Mbit-Verbindung da keine Haushalt hat.
Das ist echt krass, dass man heutzutage überhaupt noch... Also ich hab mir jetzt ja gerade einen neuen Server gebucht. Mehr als 100 MBit gibt es da einfach nicht. Und wenn man bedenkt, dass heute jetzt so die 25 bzw. 50 MBit im privaten Bereich langsam Standard werden, dann sind 100 MBit ja wirklich gar nichts.
Ja und für Peak-Belastung ist es ein echtes Problem. Jetzt gibt es natürlich auch viele wohl diskutierte Vorschläge, wie man das machen kann. Man kann sich halt entweder da eine Bit-Torrent-Lösung bauen oder man kann sich halt eine Content-Delivery-Lösung machen, wo man dann halt auf mehrere 100-Mbit-Server verteilt. Das Problem bei jeder Lösung ist, dass es erstmal systemadministrativen Aufwand benötigt, den ich derzeit einfach nicht zu leisten in der Lage bin. Ich habe einfach da keine Muße und Möglichkeiten. Andererseits weiß ich eben auch schon seit längerer Zeit, dass da eben demnächst der Gigabit-Port kommt. Das weiß ich zwar jetzt auch schon so lange und ich hoffe auch schon so lange, dass es dann nächste Woche endlich mal so weit ist. Jetzt weiß ich, dass ich auf jeden Fall noch bis Mitte April warten muss, aber dieses Gerät steht halt in einem Rack und dieses Rack muss umziehen. Und das ist sozusagen das, worauf alles wartet und das Umziehen selbst wartet noch darauf, dass ein Router kommen musste, der jetzt auch schon bestellt wurde, der wohl auch schon geliefert ist, der dann aber noch eingebaut, konfiguriert und so weiter werden muss. Dann muss das Ding noch umziehen und dann wird es eingebaut und dann müssen sie wahrscheinlich noch mehrere Jahrhunderte, Millionen Jahre darauf warten, dass Lemon-Soaked-Paper-Napkins nachgeliefert werden. Den hast du nicht verstanden? Lemon-Soaked-Paper-Napkins?
Also, Lemon-Soaked-Paper-Napkins.
Das ist diese großartige Szene im Perlhalter durch die Galaxis, wo sie dann irgendwann da mal so durch die Zeitenwelten auf diesem Planeten gebeamt werden in so einer Höhle, wo so ein Raumschiff ist. Und dieses Raumschiff ist komplett besetzt mit Besatzungen und mit Teilnehmern. Und das ist aber auch schon seit ein paar Millionen Jahren und wartet darauf, dass es losfliegen kann. Der Bordcomputer hat bloß am Anfang festgestellt, dass halt die Lieferung von Lemon-Soaked-Paper-Napkins noch nicht da ist und beschlossen, dass man jetzt nicht losfliegen kann und friert dann immer das komplette System in so einem Hibernation-Mode für mehrere Jahre ein, wacht dann wieder auf, stellt fest, dass die immer noch nicht da sind und so warten sie halt schon seit Ewigkeiten da drauf. Also Lemon-Soaked-Paper-Napkins sind für mich immer so das Symbol des sinnlosen Wartens. Die anderen Podcasts, also Bizz und so hat sich jetzt gerade das selbe Problem gehabt, die haben sich halt mit zum CDN behäufen. Das heißt, die haben jetzt einfach mehrere Server und machen dann so ein DNS-basiertes Round-Robin-Verfahren und sammeln dann irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch ihre Statistiken wieder zusammen. Das wäre für mich eigentlich auch das Sinnvollste, bloß dann müsste ich halt mehrere Server auch noch betreiben und im Überblick haben und so. Na ja gut, ich meine, wenn man jetzt noch so zwei, drei dazustellen würde, dann wäre es vielleicht gerade noch so zu tragen. Aber da ich halt einfach jetzt klarer Visionen habe, dass das eben das Problem sich von alleine lösen wird, weil der Server ist nämlich schnell genug an sich.
Klar, das ging mir auch bei... Vorher hatte ich ja das Problem am Hals. Das heißt, ich habe mich um den Server gekümmert, als es noch ein anderer war. Und da hatte ich ja irgendwann die schöne Situation, dass einfach das Netzwerk voll ist, die Netzwerkkarte. Ansonsten ging es dem Server ganz dufte. Der hätte noch zehnmal so viel gekonnt.
Ja, ich habe ja auch keine Apache da drauf. Ich habe da irgendwie einen Lighty drauf, der hat also mit der Delivery von mehreren Dateien jetzt so auch kein Problem. Und das Ding hat auch genug RAM. Das heißt, wenn da so eine Sendung ausgeliefert wird, dann liegt die halt nicht mehr wirklich auf der Platte rum, sondern wahrscheinlich einfach komplett im Cache. Ist alles nicht so das Thema. Und das Problem wird sich irgendwie von alleine lösen. Und ich bin auch dankbar für die vielen klugen Vorschläge, die ich da bekommen habe. Aber...
Und hier, wenn du das...
Ich kann die alle jetzt nicht machen. Die BitTorrent-Lösung ist ein anderes Problem. Da hatte ich ja auch schon vor einiger Zeit mal skizziert, wie man das machen kann. Immer unter der Maßgabe, dass man eben seine... Also klar könnte ich jetzt einfach BitTorrent machen. Das Problem ist, ich will halt die Statistiken haben. Und... Die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu machen, ist einen Trecker zu fahren, der halt Download-Events wegläuft. Da gibt es einfach keinen.
Die machen immer nur Seats und Peers?
Ja, das bekloppt an dieser ganzen BitTorrent-Szene. Ich meine, die können ja noch so viel behaupten, wie toll und wichtig das ist, Linus-Distributionen durch die Welt zu schieben. Aber Tatsache ist, das ist einfach mal ein Rob-Copierer-Tool. Und die User-Interfaces sind darauf ausgelegt, dass ein Mann allein vor seiner Maschine sitzt und in der Regel eben diese Daten nicht hat. Das heißt, für Seeding und schon gar nicht für Massenseeding von vielen Files ist einfach kein BitTorrent-System ausgelegt. Also vielleicht gibt es eins, dann kenne ich es nicht. Aber ich habe mal rumgefragt und es gab allgemein nur Fragezeichen und so Anforderungen wie ich gebe dir eine Liste von Dateien, die gefälligst gesiedelt werden sollen und die dann vielleicht auch noch in verschiedenen Unterverzeichnissen liegen und nicht alle in einem Download-Ort. Was halt das Problem hat, dass du auch nicht zwei Dateien unterschiedlicher Art mit gleichem Namen. Also angenommen, du hast zwei Dateien mit unterschiedlichem Inhalt, die aber denselben Dateinamen haben. Wie willst du die in einem Ort nach speichern? Geht nicht. Wenn du einen Server hast, wo Daten drauf sind, irgendwelche Daten, dann kann das schon sein, dass mal eben zwei Dateien auch gleich heißen. Sich aber in einem anderen Verzeichnis befinden. Recording-Punkt. Also wenn dein Ordner sozusagen sagt, was es ist und das Pfeil selbst ist halt nicht. Klar, da kann man halt irgendwie auch alles noch machen, aber das muss man halt auch alles erst noch mal machen und du musst halt immer irgendwie sicherstellen, dass es nicht ist. Und diese ganze Software ist halt einfach bekloppt.
Und dann brauchst du noch eine SSD wegen den Seeks, weil die ja, wenn du viele Torrens...
Ja, das heißt ja nicht, dass die auch alle gefragt sind. Also er muss es ja nur anbieten.
Torrent geht schon super. Das muss man sagen, das wäre schon eine gute Lösung.
Insgesamt würde die Last auf jeden Fall bei dem Server runtergehen. Aber es gibt halt einfach da nichts, was so Out of the Box ohne Weiteres funktioniert und ich weiß, man kannte da jetzt viel Zeit drauf verwenden und dann irgendwie alles mal testen, aber ich habe diese Zeit einfach nicht.
Und warum publishen man da, also ich kenne mich da nicht so aus, aber warum publishen man da nicht einfach bei iTunes und lässt dir die Lode händeln?
iTunes publish gar nicht.
Also dein Podcast, wenn du den da...
Das ist so ein common misunderstanding. iTunes hält keine Dateien vor. iTunes ist keine Distributionsplattform. iTunes ist lediglich ein Directory von Podcasts. Und das liefert dir auch schon den Feed, den du bietest. Also wenn du da subscribst, dann kriegst du von dem Directory in dein iTunes die URL von deiner Domäne. Und da mischen die sich überhaupt nicht ein. Ich glaube, wenn sie das tun würden, dann wäre der Schritt auch zum Verkaufen sehr kurz. Aber das machen sie halt nicht, weil sie für diesen ganzen Scheiß keine Verantwortung übernehmen wollen oder keine Lust haben, sich durch irgendwelche unflättigen, dahergelaufenen Podcaster mit Fekalsprache sich da ihr schönes, glänzendes Image zu vergeigen zu lassen. Wissen schon, ne? iPod-Apps.
Aber das wäre sozusagen nochmal eine Dienstleistung, die da voll gefragt wäre, wenn man jetzt so Professional Podcasts, Distribution, Hosting gegen kleine Münzen.
Ey, sowas wie den iPhone Store irgendwie für Podcasting. Ich glaube, da würden eine ganze Menge Leute Apple wirklich die Füße lecken dafür. Aber die haben, glaube ich, gerade keinen Interesse daran, sich die Füße lecken zu lassen. Machen schon genug. Ja, ich könnte mir das gut vorstellen. Für bestimmte Anwendungen wäre das wirklich der Knaller. Und dann ist halt auch so dieses 70-30% Sharing-Modell, wenn du dann dafür überhaupt gar keine Infrastruktur mehr aufrecht erhalten musst, ist das halt einfach total super. Du kannst halt irgendwie Episode für Episode verkaufen. Und das ist natürlich jetzt für so ein Format nicht das, was ich vorschlagen wollen würde. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Aber stell mal vor, du machst halt so Special-Interest-Podcasts für die klassischen vertikalen Märkte. Das weiß ich.
Die klassischen vertikalen Märkte?
Na ja, so was weiß ich. Aktienanalyse. Daily.
Das ist so einzig, was uns zu dem Thema immer einfällt. Oder irgendwelche Pappasen, die sich hinsetzen und sagen, muss steigen, muss steigen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, da ist Musik drin, da ist irgendwie Geld. Wie sagt man so schön? Fantasie. Diese Fantasie wäre dann auch in so einem Podcast. Oder denkt ihr irgendwas anderes aus, wo es um Geld geht und wo die Bewertung eines Experten durchaus auch Geld wert sein kann. Und dann kannst du natürlich so auf Micropayment-Basis schon einer bestimmten Zielgruppe regelmäßig Zeuche unterholen. Bloß musst du halt diese ganze Abrechnungsgeschichte noch machen. Und das sind alles so Sachen, die ich denke, die auch über kurz oder lang kommen werden. Und die Software dafür, die wird auch über kurz oder lang kommen. Nur wäre da natürlich schon die Möglichkeit für Apple, auch mit iTunes, was zu reißen. Ob sie das tun werden, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Aber generell sollte man dieses Thema eigentlich mal so einen Content gleichmäßig verteilen, dass das Netz da so ein bisschen mehr Intelligenz mit hat.
Das Netz sollte mehr Intelligenz haben. Ja, das fand ich auch schon immer.
Insbesondere die Nutzer.
Aber nur verteilen geht ja easy. Also ich meine, jeder Arsch und sein Bruder, in Anführungsstrichen, bietet auch jetzt Content Delivery Networks an. Und es gibt ja hier irgendwie so eine Seite, ich weiß nicht mehr wo, da sind die alle gelistet und was da gerade so für, da kannst du eingeben, wie viel Gigabyte du brauchst und wie es verteilt werden soll. Und er sagt ja, welche die billigste ist.
Was, was, was, wo, wie, was, wo gibt es so eine Seite?
Habe ich mal vor Ewigkeit mich da mal durch Zufall drüber gestolpert, aber nicht gebucht, mal muss ich noch mal gucken. Was kostet ein Schweinegeld, das ist ähnlicher. Ja, genau, also Amazon S3, also die Quintessenz war eigentlich, dass hier so Amazon S3 oder so oder Host Europe macht ja auch so was, dass es halt schon ziemlich teuer ist und dass man da mit eigenen Mitteln eigentlich viel billiger wegkommt, aber da man halt keinen Bock auf eigene Lösungen hat, dann ja, also so ein Content-Delivery-Network, es gibt auf jeden Fall genug.
Ich meine, ob man wirklich billiger ist, ist die Frage. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass S3 so erfolgreich wäre, wenn man mit eigenen Mitteln sehr viel billiger wegkommen würde, weil du musst ja auch noch so was reinrechnen, wie Personal, Rechner kaufen, warten.
Skalierbarkeit.
Skalierbarkeit, Pipapo, da kommt schon eine ganze Menge rein.
Vielleicht war das auch in diesem High-Scalability-Block oder irgendwo bin ich da drüber gestolpert, als ich mich mal mit Content-Delivery-Networks beschäftigt habe.
Ich hab mal geguckt, was S3 so kosten würde für so Mobile-Macs mit unseren Download-Zahlen und das wären so etwa 300 Euro im Monat. Dafür kann man sich schon ein paar Server hinstellen.
Die Kosten, die die Bandbreite erzeugen würde.
Pi mal Down-Zoo.
Bei Carsradio Express würde es mich schlicht und ergreifend töten. Das muss auch noch billiger werden.
Bei denen hab ich ja tatsächlich, ich hab mal bei deren Support angefragt, nach dem Motto, ihr habt auch da Public-URLs und so und es steht nix von Bandbreitenbegrenzung, wenn ich euch da 10 Euro im Monat überweise, was sagt ihr dazu? Und da kann man schon so zurück, wenn ihr Netwinneslein lassen wolltet, also machen sie nicht. Schalten sie einfach an, wegen, abwägen. Also haben wir irgendwo klein drinstehen, so bei übermäßiger Benutzung.
Im Chat kommt ja sowas wie Rapid Share. Das geht ja nun gar nicht. Wie gesagt, es ist ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne das Problem, dass wir jetzt nicht wüssten, wie wir eine große Datei vielen Leuten zugänglich machen. Da ist ja BitTorrent die einfachste Methode und die ist ja auch total naheliegend. Nur, ich möchte halt gerne eine Lösung haben, die uns eben auch die entsprechenden Statistiken liefert. Und das ist bei BitTorrent zwar theoretisch ganz toll, aber praktisch knifflig noch. Und bei Mirrors und so anderen Systemen, da kriegst du halt einfach dann nicht diese fine-grained Informationen, die du gerne haben möchtest. Weil man will ja auch ein bisschen wissen, wen denn das nun interessiert. Also nicht wen das interessiert, sondern auf welche Art und Weise das alles irgendwie nachgefragt wird. Freutscher Versprecher. Na ja, also wen im Sinne von, willst du halt schon mal wissen, wie viele Leute benutzen iTunes, wie viele Leute könnten theoretisch jetzt mit, verwenden schon Miro und könnten auf BitTorrent umsteigen und solche, also dass man einfach mal auch so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, mit welcher technischen Ausrüstung so die Hörer eigentlich alle am Start sind. Na ja, gut. Aber wir wollten ja hier eigentlich über Macintoshes reden und zumindest steht das ja hier im Titel. Dem werden wir nicht unbedingt immer gerecht. Aber wir probieren es jetzt mal. Ich hab mal ein neues Tool auf den Plan gerufen, nachdem hier in letzter Zeit so viel mit Google Wave gearbeitet wurde. Habe ich mal Thinklinkr benutzt oder mal einfach ein Dokument erstellt. Ihr habt jetzt auch schon ein bisschen drauf rumgeklickt, was ist euer Gefühl so?
Dieses Thinklinkr?
Sieht auf jeden Fall, mir gefällt es sofort.
Vielleicht soll man kurz sagen, was es ist. Das ist eine Web-Dienst, eine Webseite, eine Web-App, die man im Browser benutzt und da kann man Outlines erstellen.
Ich fand es vom Ansatz her gut, in der Praxis eher nicht so dufte. Als ich es erstmal aufgemacht habe, war es unglaublich langsam, weil diese Liste sofort wieder ran voll war mit irgendwelchem Zeug schon. Das finde ich immer sehr lustig. Wenn man irgendeinen Online-Tool einem Stress-Test unterziehen will, dann muss man wahrscheinlich Mobile-Max-Hörer drauf loslassen. Dann kriegen die das schon platt. Und es sind halt so Kleinigkeiten, die ich ziemlich nervig finde. Also wenn man sich einloggt, dass man auf ein ganz anderes kommt, auf ein ganz anderes Sheet oder wie auch immer Dokument. Zumindest bei mir jetzt zweimal so. Und diese Hilfe, die unten angezeigt wird mit den ganzen Shortcuts am Anfang, die ich dann auch nicht wiederfinde, nachdem ich sie einmal zugelegt habe. Also erst macht ihr mir einen Bildschirm zu in einem Moment, in dem ich sie nicht brauche und finde ich sie nicht wieder.
Du schickst auf Hight und dann blinkt hier unten noch dreimal irgendwie unten das Icon da. Ist es jetzt etwas geblinkt?
Ja, aber wir haben dir schon Mühe gegeben. Also bevor wir vielleicht zu den Nachteilen kommen, vielleicht erst mal zu den Vorteilen. Das ist überhaupt der erste richtig gute Outliner, den ich gesehen habe, der einfach so funktioniert, wie ein Outliner zu funktionieren hat. Nämlich er bietet einem hierarchische Gruppierung und du kannst halt auch komplette Sub-Hierarchien wegmoven. Das heißt, es ist sehr einfach, schnell Indentation, Authentation zu machen, also die Hierarchieebene zu wechseln, beziehungsweise Elemente, die auf der gleichen Hierarchieebene sind, untereinander zu vertauschen. Um so Gedanken zu strukturieren, beziehungsweise um solche Outliner-Listen zu erstellen, ist das das erste Tool, was jetzt im Web an die Qualität, die ich jetzt von den Desktop-Anwendungen gewohnt bin, zumindest ein bisschen rankommt. Also es ist noch nicht the same, aber es ist definitiv ganz brauchbar. Und der Vorteil ist natürlich, dass es eben wie bei Wave oder EtherPad, also die halt mehr so auf Text orientiert sind, eben hier kollaborativ arbeiten kannst. Und es ist noch nicht so super stabil. Und ich habe hier unterschiedliche Ergebnisse gehabt mit Safari und Firefox. Also da scheint schon noch einige Arbeit zu tun zu sein. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall erstmal da. Und es ist jetzt auch nicht komplett zusammengebrochen. Du hast auch eine Historie in dem ganzen Ding mit drin. Und kannst wie beliebig importieren und exportieren. Irgendwelche Dateiformate. Das ist schon alles ganz prima. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ich wollte mir jetzt mal einen EtherPad-Server packen. Das fand ich ja ganz toll, bis dann Google das eingestampft hat. Und jetzt haben sie es ja wieder als Open Source veröffentlicht. Und mittlerweile gibt es das auch offensichtlich.
Wir haben das auch schon im Einsatz.
War die Installation schwer? Hast du die gemacht?
Erdgrass hat das gemacht, genau.
Er hat da glaube ich schon so zwei, drei Tage mit gerestelt, weil da irgendwie Java, Fubar und Bats. Und Java auf FreeBSD-Maschinen ist ja auch immer so ein Thema.
Die Piratenpartei hat auch sich ein EtherPad aufgesetzt. Also so für Text ist es super. Aber ich finde halt, dass Text einfach für bestimmte Dinge nicht super ist. Jetzt zum Beispiel haben wir hier die Liste mit drin. Und nicht nur, dass wir diese Liste haben und die auch jederzeit schnell eine Reihenfolge ändern können, sondern man kann dann auch gleich noch die Check-Buttons anmachen und dann eben die Sachen auch gleich noch abhaken. Das sind halt alles so Sachen, die du jetzt bei Wave und den ganzen anderen so nicht hast. Was war nochmal dieses Wave? Na ja, Wave ist das, was jetzt wohl...
Das ist doch jetzt bei den Chinesen gekauft worden, oder?
Also ich muss auch sagen, hier, das ist...
Wave ist das Team... Also was ich auch bis vor kurzem noch nicht wusste, dieses EtherPad, die Leute waren vorher schon im Wave-Team und sind da rausgegangen, weil sie da auf die Richtung keinen Bock hatten und haben dann halt... Der Max schmatzt. Ja, aber die Hörer sind schuld, weil wir haben nämlich hier wieder so eine, ja, das war jetzt die falsche Frage, Max. Ja, jetzt kann ich natürlich wieder nicht antworten, weil ich es mir ja hier nicht hingelegt habe. Auf jeden Fall sehr dankbar. Ein großes, dickes Paket kam irgendwie an mit Tonnen von Gummibärchen. Sah so ein bisschen nach Fabrikware aus, weil es so bekannte Markenware ohne die bekannte Markenverpackung. Von daher habe ich den Eindruck, dass das so ein bisschen vom Vliesband gefallen. Vielleicht wären wir ja auch vom Vliesband gehört. Machen wir jetzt auch mal eine Sendung hier wie vom Vliesband.
Genau, die von Zeichen, indem du...
Was? Du kannst ein Zeichen geben, in dem in Zukunft in der Gummibärchentüte irgendwas anderes drin ist. So ein kleines M, packst ein kleines M dazu. Das ist das Zeichen.
Worüber wollte ich jetzt gerade reden, als du angefangen hast zu schmassen?
Du warst noch bei Wave und dem Team.
Ich kann da keine URL zu nennen, aber wie ich es gehört habe, ist Wave-Team in eine Richtung marschiert. Teil dieses Wave-Teams hatte darauf keinen Bock, hat EtherPad gestartet. EtherPad war 0,9% riesen Erfolg, because they focused on the minimum und so weiter. Das übliche. Dann waren sie total erfolgreich. Dann hat Google sie wieder zurückgekauft. Von wegen Kreativität bei Google während der Arbeit. Ich hab auch dieses Re-Mail, was da neulich wieder einverleibt wurde.
Ach, das haben sie auch ausgegründet gehabt?
Die waren halt auch vorher schon.
Die waren bei Gmail dabei, ne?
Also irgendwie haben die immer so Leute im Team, dann steigen ein paar Frustrate raus, starten irgendwie so ein Start-up und sind total erfolgreich, weil sie irgendwie einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen haben und dann sehen sie es wieder ein und kaufen die wieder zurück.
Meinst du, das machen sie wegen überragender Frustration oder meinst du mehr so die Chance?
Ich glaube, dass Google schon gemerkt hat, dass sie bei Wave sich irgendwie so ein bisschen vergaloppiert haben. Ich meine, an sich ist die Idee ja ganz toll, aber so wie es dann rüber kam, es war einfach eine schwerfällige, dicke, fette Sau. Sie hätten das gleich mal mit diesen Extensions, das hätten sie einfach mal von Anfang an einfach mal weglassen sollen und da sehr viel schlanker an Start gehen sollen und sich so langsam hinaus evolvieren. Und ich vermute mal, dass sie da quasi durch diesen Kauf von Etherpads ein bisschen zu Kreuze gekrochen sind und gesehen haben, okay, alles klar, wir müssen da einen anderen Pfad einschlagen und dann holen wir uns doch mal die Leute, die diese Vision auch klar vertreten.
Die sind vielleicht auch ein bisschen von ihrem eigenen Erfolg überrannt worden. Welchem Erfolg? Ich meine, die haben damals diese Demo gegeben auf dieser Google-Entwickler-Konferenz. Auf der Google IO. Auf der Google IO und alle waren total begeistert und die halbe Welt wollte plötzlich Base-Accounts haben und die waren vielleicht einfach lange nicht so weit, das wirklich liefern zu können. Und wenn du dann so einen fetten Erfolg in Haus hast, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass dann auch das Management ziemlich trampelt und sagt, wir müssen das jetzt mal in den Start bringen und dann haben die da viele Überstunden gemacht und dann Rundinvitations ausgeschmissen ohne Ende. Und wenn man sich das jetzt dann guckt, ich finde, am Anfang war es wirklich unerträglich, aber es ist jetzt noch nicht so, als ob es jetzt ein tolles, das perfekte Tool wäre, aber es entwickelt sich und es wird besser. Und das ist, ich glaube, Wave, irgendwann kann daraus nochmal was werden. Aber es ist halt viel zu früh am Tageslicht gekommen.
Ja, aber sie haben schon eine Menge Pulver vergeudet, muss man sagen. So, wie auch immer. Also diese ganzen kollaborativen Tools im Web, die gehen auf jeden Fall voran. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass so eine Outliner-Funktion noch in mehr Tools Eingang erhält. Dass man einfach mehr Möglichkeiten hat, dazu zu wechseln und dass sich das einfach noch ein bisschen besser entwickelt. Ansonsten auf Mac kann man nur Omni-Outliner nach wie vor empfehlen. Das ist so eigentlich der Outliner TM. Ich bin nicht ganz so zufrieden, wie sich das Tool entwickelt hat, so über die Jahre. Insbesondere der letzte große Versionswechsel fand meine Zustimmung nur eingeschränkt, obwohl ich die aktuelle Version benutze, aus anderen Gründen. Aber da waren so ein paar Sachen drin, die ich nicht mag. Ich würde lieber einen haben, der jetzt nicht so ein eigenes Checkbox-User-Interface macht. Sie sind da so ein bisschen im Hinblick auf, wie es dann gedruckt aussieht. Sie sind so mehr so ein Rich-Text-Weg gegangen. Und wenn mich irgendwas nervt bei der Arbeit, dann ist es Rich-Text. Also Programme, die mir irgendwie Rich-Text erlauben, was ist das elende Problem mit, kopierst du irgendwas rein, dann ist alles rot und 5 Punkten groß.
Man will nur Texte gebrauchen.
Klar, man kann dann noch anders pasten, man kann das dann irgendwie alles zurückgeben, man muss es halt auch machen. Ich will einfach nur so Text und Outline. Mehr nicht. Ich will einfach so, diese Omni-Outliner, so ein riesen Checkbox am Anfang, so Kill, Rich-Text, einfach nicht, einfach aus, weg, ich brauch das nicht, meine Informationen, weil das führt dann auch dazu, dass man vielleicht sogar Formatierungen benutzt, um irgendwas wichtig werden zu lassen. Anstatt dass man das durch seine Struktur ausdrückt. Weil darum geht es ja eigentlich bei der ganzen Sache. Also das finde ich so ein bisschen...
Aber Rich-Text an sich ist ja schon eine tolle Sache.
Zwei Schriften ist schon gut.
Also ich finde Rich-Text toll. Ich bin vorhin von Rich-Text. Jetzt bin ich im Outliner.
Im Mail-Programm.
Machst du deine Mail in Rich-Text?
Nein.
Wo machst du denn Rich-Text aus? So bei uns hier in der Firma. Da ist ja immer so das Problem, wir haben so Admins, die sind so Linux, Open Source, Faschos. Und dann gibt es halt die Business-Leute, die halt Microsoft Office nehmen. Und jeder, der jetzt aber ankommt mit einem neuen Rechner, der kriegt erstmal per Default Open Office installiert. Und dann gibt es halt immer so dieses Problem mit dem Hin und Herreichen von Dokumenten. Und dann ist das ja eigentlich das Gleiche. Und es kann ja Microsoft Office lesen und benutzt mal Open Office und ist gratis und so weiter. Dann machen die das auf. Dann ändert sich aber irgendwo ein Umbruch und dann schicken sie es zurück und dann bombt das MS Office auseinander. Und es gibt da jede Regelmäßig Grabenkämpfe. Irgendwie schon ein paar Mal gesagt, nimm doch einfach hier Rich Text, kann einfach jeder öffnen. So gibt es auf allen Plattformen überall.
Also du redest jetzt von RTF.
Achso, ja, wie? Und das ist was anderes als...
Also mit Rich Text meine ich überhaupt Text, der sich formatieren lässt.
Achso, nee, ich meine jetzt schon richtig RTF, ja.
Dieses total alte Format, was ich irgendwann mal probiert hatte, ist die Assemblieren ohne Anleitung.
Das ist LaTeX. Habe ich letztens rausgefunden. Das ist sozusagen von LaTeX oder TeX abgeleitet, ja. Aber es ist auch lesbar.
Ja, lesbar ist es.
Ich dachte auch, es ist ein Binärformat, aber war dann ganz überrascht, dass das eigentlich voll sinnvoll ist. Und das ist von Microsoft entwickelt. Der erste, der Rich Text implementiert hat von Microsoft, war tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch Apple mit Text, wie hieß das früher? Keine Ahnung, irgendwie so. Nee, quatsch, MS Office for Mac war das erste Rich RTF-fähige Programm, sozusagen. Vor tausenden von Jahren.
Auf dem Mac meinst du?
Nee, ich glaube insgesamt war es sogar das erste Programm, was das dran hatte.
RTF ist halt was WordPad bei Microsoft Windows erwähnt hat.
Microsoft hat das entwickelt, aber irgendwie hatte ich sowas gelesen, wie von wegen das erste Mal eingebaut haben sie es in MS Word for Mac. Na ja, anyway, auf jeden Fall so.
Ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass es auf Next das erste Mal sozusagen außerhalb von Windows existiert hat.
Ich hab irgendwie letzten, also keine Ahnung, ich guck mir nochmal in die WGP, jetzt hab ich hier was angefangen mit Rich Text.
Ist ja egal. Also ich meinte jetzt Rich Text als Konzept, nämlich dass du es formatieren kannst. Und das stört mich halt häufig. Outliner und RTF, das geht auch nicht zusammen, weil diese Struktur da drin nicht so. Aber das ist einfach, ich würde halt einfach gerne mein Outliner-Dokument machen und definitiv einfach die benutzen wie so ein Standard Coding Text Editor, wo einfach jede Formatierung verloren geht in dem Moment, wo du das reinmachst.
Ne, da unterschreib ich auch völlig. Es klang halt nur so für den Moment, als würdest du jetzt hier Rich Text an sich und dann dachte ich, ich muss jetzt mal noch eine Line zerbrechen für RTF.
Ich hab übrigens einen total geilen Tipp, wie man in der deutschen Wikipedia das hinkriegt, dass der Artikel viel, viel ausführlicher und besser wird. Man muss oben in der URL das DE-Punkt durch ein EN ersetzen.
The first RTF reader and writer shipped in 1987 as part of Microsoft Word 3.0 for Macintosh which implemented RTF version 1.0 specification.
Welches Programm?
Microsoft Word 3.0 for Macintosh.
Na gut, also Microsoft hat sozusagen das zuerst auf dem...
Naja, genau, aber auf dem Mac zuerst.
Ach so, okay, alles klar. Interessant. Ja, ist nicht alles... Es war nicht alles schlecht.
Ne, also... Und wie gesagt, so viel Tricks da.
Aber wir dürfen eigentlich nicht über Windows reden, sonst können wir wieder hauen.
Das stimmt. Wenn man über kleine Betriebssysteme sich lustig macht, dann kriegt man...
Ja, wir haben nämlich keine Ahnung. Nächstes Thema. Womit machen wir weiter? Ich hab... Hat jemand von euch da so... Also ich... Ich bin gerade dabei... Ich hab grad viel zu tun. Und wie das immer so ist, wenn man viel zu tun hat, ihr kennt das Problem vielleicht...
Kauft man sich erstmal eine ToDo-Liste.
Da denkt man dann wieder drüber nach, ob man nicht das doch vielleicht nochmal probiert. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Ansätze ich in meinem Leben schon hatte, ToDo-Software einzuführen. Das ist jetzt bestimmt das zehnte Mal. Und alle neun Male vorher waren einfach ein einziger Fail. Nichts hat funktioniert. Palm hat nicht funktioniert. Irgendwie. Diese ersten... Auf Mac OS 9, da gab's ja so diverse Tools, die so was machen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie sie alle hießen. So Nau und... Alles ging nicht. Und es ging vor allem deshalb eigentlich nicht, weil man ja immer so am Rechner sitzen musste. Und die Ideen, was man mal so tun könnte oder die Momente, wo man mal was abhaken muss, ist halt irgendwie mobil. Palm war in gewisser Hinsicht das erste Versprechen, aber mit diesem Stift und überhaupt mit diesem Palm, das hat einfach für mich hinten und vorne nicht funktioniert. Jetzt ist viel Zeit vergangen. Dann habe ich vor einiger Zeit noch mal, dann ging es ja auf dem iPhone richtig zur Sache. Und dann gab es so im Wesentlichen zwei Contender, nämlich Things und Omni. Omni Focus. Die beide mittlerweile mit einer Macintosh-Anwendung und mit einer iPhone-Anwendung da sind, wo halt dann das Versprechen natürlich ist, dass du eben auf dem Desktop und so weiter deine Sachen machen kannst und so. Das habe ich dann auch mal eine Weile probiert mit beiden und ich bin bei beiden irgendwie nicht, kam mein Kopf einfach nicht mit. Bei Things war seinerzeit das Problem, dass das Things auf dem iPhone bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht konnte, was das Things auf dem Mac machte, was ich überhaupt nicht verstanden habe. Also da waren einfach bestimmte Features, also insbesondere diese Areas of Responsibility, wie sie das nennen, waren halt einfach nicht da. Und da war ich irgendwie nicht bereit, mich auf eine Software einzuladen. Die einfach jetzt auf etwas, was sinken soll.
Das erste ToDo auf deiner ToDo-Liste. Learn how to use the ToDo-List-Software.
So kommt OmniFocus gleich hoch, wenn du es frisch installierst. OmniFocus wiederum ist total geprägt von The OmniWay, der ja ganz interessant ist. Und sie haben ja mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Sachen in diesem Bereich. Es gibt ja auch OmniPlan jetzt für so richtig Projektmanagement. Es ist alles immer so eine Sache, weil auf der einen Seite will man das total einfach haben, auf der anderen Seite will man natürlich auch für die extremen Fälle das machen. Und was so ein Grundproblem eigentlich erstmal ist, was ja auch der Grund ist, warum man überhaupt so eine Software benutzen will, weil man ist ja selber verpeilt. Das heißt, man schnallt eigentlich überhaupt nicht, wie man seine Arbeit strukturieren sollen sollte, wie man das überhaupt auffasst. Und deswegen kriegt man nichts auf die Reihe. Oder unter anderem deswegen kriegt man nichts auf die Reihe. Dann kommt dann so eine Software und dann weißt du da gar nicht mit umzugehen, weil du diese Konzepte gar nicht im Kopf hast oder überhaupt keinen Ansatz hast. Also das ist auch erstmal so eine Sache. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich habe dann jetzt vor ein paar Tagen Things, was ich mir fürs iPhone schon mal gekauft hatte, nochmal ausgegraben und mal geschaut, wie sich das so weiter entwickelt hat und siehe da, mittlerweile konnte es die Dinge, die es damals nicht konnte. Also die letzten X-Updates haben dann tatsächlich auch eine Verbesserung gebracht. Und auch diese Mac-Version ist vorangekommen. Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Logik von Things ganz überzeugend und ich werde das jetzt nochmal testen. Also was ich sehr interessant finde bei Things ist, gucken, ob ich das jetzt gut zusammenkriege, also sie minimieren so ein bisschen das, was dir unmittelbar aufs Auge gedrückt wird. Also du hast jetzt nicht nur so Due-Dates oder sowas, die du mit eintragen kannst, sondern es gibt so explizit so eine Today-Liste und du kannst halt einzelne Tasks explizit in diese Today-Liste reinwerfen, sie können sich aber auch automatisch, wenn sie dann eben due sind, da reinwerfen. Das heißt, du kannst die Dinge eben auch sagen, ich will das jetzt mal einfach jetzt mal tun, auch wenn es noch nicht unbedingt fällig wäre und dann bringst du es dir quasi auch in deinen Aufmerksamkeitsfokus rein. Und was auch sehr schön ist, also ich kann jetzt über Omni-Fokus gerade nicht so viel sagen, das hat mich zuletzt einfach nur verwirrt, als ich das benutzt habe. Aber bei Things kannst du dann Projekte machen und dann eben diese Areas of Responsibility. Und das ist eigentlich eine sehr schöne Abstraktion. Areas of Responsibility sind nämlich so Sachen, wozu es irgendwie gehört und die an sich nicht enden.
Achso, das ist so dieses GTD-Dings?
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe diese Bücher nicht gelesen. Ich nehme für mich nicht in Anspruch, diesen GTD-Gedanken verstanden zu haben. Ich meine, am Ende will man natürlich, dass die Dinge erledigt sind. Aber diese Konzepte von GTD habe ich jetzt weder verinnerlicht, noch weiß ich, inwiefern die jetzt bei Things dadurch jetzt kommen. Ich glaube nur, einfach gerade mal verstanden zu haben, wie sie es meinen und fand das ganz logisch. Deswegen wollte ich das hier kurz wiedergeben. Also du hast so eine Area of Responsibility. Das sind halt so Sachen, quasi so die groben Gruppen, in denen du Dinge tust. Zum Beispiel ist Mobile Max da sowas. Oder, was weiß ich, dieses Studio hier. Und dann gibt es halt Dinge, die sich auf dieses Studio beziehen, die ich tun will. Was weiß ich, irgendwas bauen, kaufen, verkaufen, um reparieren und so weiter. Das wären dann die Tasks. Und außerdem gibt es noch Projects. Und Project ist sozusagen eine Gruppe von Einzelaufgaben. Und unterscheidet sich eben von diesen Areas of Responsibility dadurch, dass es eben auch fertig sein kann. Also, wenn du etwas in Angriff nehmen willst im Kontext von etwas, dann ist halt der Kontext von etwas, ist diese Area of Responsibility, wozu es irgendwie dazugehört. Dann machst du da ein Projekt mit, ich will mir das und das bauen. Und dann schreibst du da die einzelnen Tasks rein. Recherche, kaufen, zusammenschrauben, löten, testen, fertig. Sodass du dann diese einzelnen Tasks auch automatisch in einer Reihenfolge hast und eben immer nur der nächste Task dann auch automatisch auftaucht, wenn du eben den vorherigen abgehakt hast. Und das erscheint mir jetzt ganz gut. Was mir dabei aber wieder aufgefallen ist, und wo ich so eine eingebaute Hoffnung gerade habe...
Jetzt neu mit eingebaute Hoffnung?
Ja, mit eingebaute Hoffnung in Bezug auf das iPhone. Das Syncing zwischen Desktop-Applikationen und iPhone-Applikationen ist einfach die Hölle. Weil die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu Syncing ist, dass eben auf beiden Rechnern beide Programme laufen und du sie halt auch noch im selben Netz hast. Sodass sie sich halt über Bonjour sehen und dann automatisch Synken. Aber warum, wenn es nicht möglich ist, eine iPhone-Applikation mit einer Desktop-Applikation zu Synken über den Weg, wie man es eben sonst auch alles synkt, nämlich über iTunes oder beziehungsweise über diesen Sync-Vorgang.
Oder über the fucking Internets.
Oder über the fucking Internet. Ich meine, das können die Programme ja selber machen. Das ist ja nicht das Ding.
Machen sie aber auch in vielen Fällen nicht.
Manche tun das, Sinks tut das leider nicht. Das wäre auch ganz interessant. Du hast ja vorhin hier Evernote als Notizblock eingeführt. Die machen das ja wiederum sehr wohl.
Das basiert quasi darauf.
Aber jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau, wo es herkommt. Aber es gibt auch dieses Gerücht. Oder war das ein Gerücht? War das eine Ankündigung? Dass jetzt im nächsten iPhone, da ist eine iPhone-Version, ich glaube in diesem 3.2. SDK vom iPad ist das irgendwie drin, dass Programme halt Folder definieren können, die mitgesynkt werden.
Ja, es gibt wohl irgendwie. Ich glaube, das ist in erster Linie für iWork-Dokumente gedacht. Ich weiß nicht mehr, über welchem Weg das war, über iTunes oder wahrscheinlich über iTunes.
Genau, das heißt, du steckst das Teil dann rein?
Ich möchte sowas nicht.
Du kannst das ja auch over the air machen, aber ich finde das ja auch gut. Das steht dir ja frei, aber was dir nicht frei steht, ist es über iTunes zu machen. Und das finde ich sollte halt möglich sein. Ich will das einfach reinstecken und dann wissen, es ist gesynkt. Ich will nicht in jedem einzelnen Programm das starten und das mit Netz und Synken. Ich will das einfach reinstecken und dann weiß ich, alle meine Programme sind gesynkt. Egal, was es ist, alles ist einfach gesynkt.
Ich möchte diesen Zustand erraten, ohne irgendwas irgendwo reinstecken zu müssen. Ich möchte einfach immer wissen, dass alles gesynkt ist. Ich möchte, dass das so läuft wie bei Google Mail, wo mein Adressbuch immer magically gesynkt ist. So muss das sein.
Ja gut, aber es ist halt auch nur das Adressbuch, was gesynkt ist.
Ja, das muss mit allen so sein.
Das geht ja gar nicht nur im Android, das geht ja auch auf dem iPhone über Internet machen.
Du willst halt dieses Internet mal zum Synken benutzen.
Aber du kannst ja nicht deine 32 GB Movies... Warum nicht? Weißt du warum?
Ja gut, also Movies nicht, aber jetzt halt so Data-Kram schon. Ich finde das halt auch ein bisschen nervig, dass man da immer ein Kabel anstecken muss zum Synken. Andererseits habe ich auch keinen Bock, dass ich jetzt irgendwie alle meine Daten immer über so einen Google-Account synke. Aber da muss es ja... Also wenn jetzt Things sozusagen...
Also die andere Option, die wir ja auch schon hier besprochen haben, die ich letztes Jahr auch nochmal häufiger getestet habe, ist ja Dropbox. Das hast du ja schon erwähnt. Bloß da gibt es dann halt auch mal wieder so kleine Probleme, nämlich vor allem, dass die Programme selbst mit so etwas nicht klarkommen, wenn du ihre Daten machst. Da gab es dieses schöne Beispiel mit Jojimbo, das ist von Barebones, also die Leute, die BB-Edit gemacht haben.
Eine Nacht bevor der besten Video-Touren überhaupt?
Ja, der auch glaube ich in zunehmendem Maße weniger Mac OS 9-artiger wird und irgendwann werde ich ihn vielleicht auch mal wieder benutzen.
Der ist schon lange nicht mehr sehr Mac OS 9-artig.
Ich habe angefangen, sie zu hassen, nachdem sie mir nicht mehr die von mir gekaufte Version zum Download anbieten. Aber egal, ich wollte nicht über BB-Edit reden, sondern das Problem mit Jojimbo ist, dass wenn du halt irgendwas sharesst und du hast halt dann das Programm auf zwei Rechnern offen und benutzt dann so etwas wie Dropbox, dass du dann halt dir eine Dateisystemkorruption oder eine Dateikorruption einfängst unter Umständen. Weil diese Programme einfach nicht darauf gemünzt sind, dass mehrere Instanzen von ihnen darauf rumlesen. Also das Prinzip der Transaktion müsstest du ja eigentlich auch im lokalen Fallsystem machen, so mit einer SQLite-Datenbank oder sowas, damit du eben für solche Sachen auch fertig bist. Also das ganze Syncing-Problem ist einfach nicht gelöst. Generell nicht. Und das finde ich, ist eine der größten Herausforderungen für die Menschheit. Für Personal Computing, auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe ja hier...
Zum Thema ToDo-Listen wollte ich ja nochmal kurz... Ich glaube ja, ToDo-Listen ist so ein...
Haben wir ein neues Thema?
Nee, nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Das ist ein ähnlicher Markt wie der mit Rauchen aufhörprodukte Markt. Sie funktionieren alle oder sie funktionieren alle nicht. Man muss einfach machen. Guck mal, ich habe hier Pflaster und Nikotin-Pflaster. Wenn man das erzählt, wäre meine Kippe...
Das Nikotin-Pflaster hat nicht funktioniert, deswegen muss ich weiter rauchen.
Oder einfach aufhören.
Einfach aufhören.
Und mit ToDo-Listen ist es genauso.
Da muss man einfach anfangen.
Die Dinge aufzuschreiben und das zu machen. Das ist alles schon immer so gut. Man muss es einfach konsequent durchziehen. Wenn man es konsequent durchzieht, dann funktioniert auch Zettel und Papier.
Ich bin halt auch nicht so ein Stiftpapier-Mensch. Aber ich habe mir letztens auch, nämlich ich, vor wenigen Tagen ToDo-Liste auch nochmal angeguckt. Und da gibt es so eine Webseite, die ich mir auch kürzlich in meinen NetNews-Wire gefüttert habe. Die heißt Well-Placed-Pixels, wo sie die schönsten Mac-Interfaces von Applikationen vorstellen. Genau, iPhone und Mac. Und da sind auch echt immer schöne Highlights dabei. Das ist mein favorisierter Weg, neue Applikationen zu finden.
Tatsächlich.
Well-Placed-Pixels. Ja, so ein paar Wochen halt. Und da kam eine ToDo-Liste durch, SimpleTask, wo es auch eine Mac- und iPhone-Version gab. Und die halt wirklich total simpel ist. Also wirklich aufs Minimum reduziert.
Wie der Name das sagt.
Genau. Und die sieht halt auch echt schick aus. Und die evaluiere ich gerade sozusagen mit... Habe ich aber erst gestern installiert, von daher kann ich da noch nicht viel zu sagen. Aber von diesen simplen ToDo-Listen machte die einen guten Eindruck, weil die auch zum Beispiel mit sowas werben, was ja uns Power-Usern besonders gut gefällt, volle Tastatursteuerung. Also das hat halt auch wirklich jede Aktion mit Zack-Zack-Peng-Peng. Ganz wichtig ist das. Und wie gesagt, sah halt auch nicht so scheiße aus wie die meisten anderen. Das jetzt nur so als Randnotiz erstmal, weil wie gesagt, ich habe...
Wie wird das da gemacht? Die haben wahrscheinlich nicht so viele Kategorisierungsmöglichkeiten.
Die haben voll wenig, genau. Die haben Farben, Flags und Checkboxen für Donnen und sowas. Da gibt es nicht so fancy Features, wie ist jetzt dann und dann fällig und gehört zu dem Projekt und so. Sondern es ist wirklich erstmal nur das, muss ich alles noch tun und ich kann es mir hier mal...
Sie ganzen ToDo-Programmen haben alle dasselbe Icon. Hier fällt echt alles nichts ein. Alle, die diesen Checkhaken.
Ja, also da sind auch...
SimpleTask, Uninstall, Internet Explorer...
Also well placed pixels fand ich auch einfach die Seite an sich schon extrem schön.
Ja, die Seite ist der Hammer.
Also das wäre mir zu einfach, diese SimpleTask.
Nee, das dachte ich mir schon, aber es gibt ja bestimmt Leute... Alle zwei werden mich aus ihr überrascht. Aber es gibt da bestimmt Leute draußen, die jetzt irgendwie denken, ja, hey Mensch, ToDo-Liste ist ein guter Punkt, könnte ich auch mal machen. Aber jetzt hier Things kostet ja auch 49 Euro, wie ich gerade sehe.
Ja, das ist ziemlich teuer. Die iPhone-Version kostet nochmal richtig Aschung. Sag ich ja, wieder brauchen abgewöhnt.
49 Euro kostet die Mac-Version.
Und vor allen Dingen, da ist noch nicht mal die iPhone-Version dabei. Das finde ich dann auch schon ein bisschen krass.
Das geht ja nicht.
Also, dass er dir nicht beides kaufen muss, ne? Naja, gut. Wie viel kostet denn die iPhone-Version?
Omni-Focus ist teurer. Und die liegen so, glaube ich, bei 80 Dollar. Hast du jetzt gerade Euro oder hast du gerade...
Euro-Ständer.
Ja, Things sind ja auch deutsche, ne?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
WellPlace Pixel, ja, die widmen sich vor allem hier den iPhone-Applikationen, habe ich fast...
Aber da waren auch schon ein paar Mac-Apps dabei auch. Also, zum Beispiel habe ich da drüber diese Articles abgefunden, um die Wikipedia zu browsen, das ist ja echt die schickste...
Ah, da können wir auch nochmal drüber reden. Haben wir das jetzt durch mit den ToDo-Listen und so? Na, dann reden wir nochmal über Articles. Wo so viele andere Leute darüber reden. Ich habe das auch probiert, aber leider, meine beiden meistgenutzten Features waren da nicht drin.
Articles ist dieses Wikipedialese-Programm.
Genau. Auch ein deutsches Produkt.
Ich habe vorher irgendwie dieses... Wie heißt denn dieses erste, was da so rauskam?
Wo ist denn eigentlich mein Telefon von?
Irgendwie hast du es da rüber geschoben.
Wir können dich gleich nachher mal kurz anrufen. Du hast es eben gerade... Wann hast du noch geklingelt?
Gehen wir mal weiter.
Da gab es ja diese erste Wikipedia ab, und die fand ich ja richtig doll scheiße. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die hieß. Wiki... Irgendwas auch mit Wiki.
Panion?
Wikipanion, ja. Die war so rotten vom Interface, fand ich.
Wikipanion ist meiner Meinung nach immer noch die erste Wahl.
Nee, fand ich doof. Also... Na, das war irgendwie alles so... Also, ich hab sie bestimmt jetzt ein halbes Jahr nicht mehr benutzt, aber es ist immer so... Dieses Gefühl, wie könnte man das beschreiben, irgendwie... So umständlich einfach.
Beschreib doch mal Artikel zum bisschen.
Was ist denn daran umständlich? Man gibt unten den Namen ein, und dann kommt die Wikipedia-Seite.
Nee, aber es ist nicht so offensichtlich. Also erstens irgendwie so einstellen, welche Wikipedia will man, wie kommt man von der einen Wikipedia zur anderen. Dann irgendwie so dieses Darstellen des Inhalts, dieses Auf- und Zuklappen. Ich weiß nicht, ich war nicht meins.
Ich bin mir von demselben Tool, ich bin mir echt nicht so sicher.
Also Artikel ist bestimmt nicht feature-complete, aber ich finde, das ist das hübscheste Wikipedia-Up-Interface so far.
Also, ich sag dir mal, was ich an Wikipanion geil finde. Erstens, wenn du halt einen langen Artikel hast, dann hast du unten einen Button und du hast halt die komplette Liste aller Abschnitte da drin. Das benutze ich fast immer, um in so einem längeren Ding mal eben schnell den richtigen Abschnitt zu finden und mich nicht dumm und dusselig zu scrollen. Und dann geht er da halt irgendwie hin und fertig.
Aber macht das nicht Artikels genauso?
Da gibt es diese Funktion einfach nicht. Doch.
Mein Telefon ist jetzt auch kaputt.
Leute, ich wüsste nicht, wo das ist.
Macht es wie ich, besorgt euch einfach drei iPhones.
Nein, Quatsch. Das Problem ist ja, wenn ich hier jetzt auch noch ein Netz anmache, dann senden wir hier die ganze Zeit GSM.
Das User-Interface ist halt so im Wesentlichen wie Safari.
Ich benutze halt statt Wikipanion, habe ich dann immer die Mobile-Variante im Safari auch immer benutzt. Mobile-Variante? Nein, einfach im Safari Wikipedia gebraucht. Also da kriegst du ja dann die Mobile oder iphone.wikipedia.org und das war irgendwie, da kam ich damit besser klar als mit Wikipanion.
Ja, na dann hast du halt, das ist halt so ein bisschen wie...
Ich finde diese Wikipedia-Seite selber auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ist doch auch nicht, nee nee.
Nee ist sie nicht. Aber, und was für mich halt auch sehr wichtig ist, was hier angeblich auch geht, aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wie, ist, ich muss halt schnell mal in die andere Sprache. Ja, das ist genau diesen genannten Problem von dir gerade, Max. Dass man halt den deutschen Artikel hat, feststellt, da steht nichts drin und dann schnell mal die Informationen braucht. Das soll aber hier irgendwie auch gehen, ne? Warte mal, warte mal, gab's nicht hier irgendwie einen Kniff?
So ein Swish oder Swipe oder Swoosh.
Bei Articles?
Ja, also es gibt bei Articles dieses Double Tap and Hold irgendwie. Dann hast du recht, zumindest die Abschnitte so grafisch, aber das finde ich eigentlich Quatsch, weil warum nicht gleich die Überschriften anzeigen?
Ja, ich meine, die sind ja gerade erst frisch. Die werden jetzt nur ein, zwei Versionen machen lassen.
Ja gut, aber man muss jetzt dann aber auch mal sagen, wie es jetzt ist und nicht, wie es vielleicht irgendwann mal sein kann. Weil Wikipanion geht ja auch voran, so ist es ja nicht.
Nee, aber ich finde halt nichtsdestotrotz einfach so das Interface von Articles, das, was sie da bisher drin haben, einfach phänomenal. Also die Darstellung des Inhalts irgendwie, auch das mit dieser Maps-Integration und sowas irgendwie.
Ja, aber wie komme ich auf die englische Version?
Hast du vielleicht in deinem General...
Warte mal, vielleicht muss man hier in den Settings mal irgendwas...
General Settings.
Nein, da gibt es keine Settings für dieses Programm. Zumindest nicht in den Settings.
So, jetzt kaufe ich mir das auch noch, damit hier gar niemand mehr was zum Thema sagen kann.
Also das Einzige, was ich jetzt schick finde, ist, dass sie halt diese Fotos mit drin haben.
Ja, aber auch hier, wenn du so Geo-Dingsbums da kriegst und so, dann kriegst du halt sowieso nichts.
Ich habe jetzt sehr probt, das stimmt. Habt ihr schon SIM-Karten fürs iPad?
So, hier dieses auch, ne? Dieses Nearby-Feature-Dingsbums wurde dann hier irgendwie die... Also ich habe es jetzt hier gerade nicht in der Hand, ne? Also, so hier Maps-Integration ist auf jeden Fall.
Also ich finde auf jeden Fall, es wird gerade gehypt in einem Maße, den ich so recht nicht verstehe, weil Wikipanion hat einfach mehr Features und zeigt die Seiten auch an.
Es sind einfach diese Design-Affinen.
Ja, ja, alles Mac-User, alles Click-Moti.
Ja, ich finde aber jetzt gerade beim Design jetzt nicht so ein... Ich meine, wo ist der Unterschied? Es sind Fotos mit drin.
Gut. Nee, auch so irgendwie, irgendwie erinnert sich das schöner, so der Text und so, keine Ahnung. So ein Clip ist auch total subjektiver.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich die Informationen nicht finde, weil ich da irgendwie in so einem riesigen Artikel 50 Minuten lang runter scrollen muss und diesen Abschnitt zu suchen, dann ist für mich das einfach kein User-Interface, sondern dann ist es irgendwie so, ach, das ist so schön.
Ich lese die Artikel auch nicht, guck sie mir mal ein. Freue mich auf der Ligaturen und so.
Du bist die ganze Zeit nur auf diesem Random-Button.
Das Bildschirm-Fixieren-Feature hast du aber ganz gut gemacht.
Das Bildschirm was? Bildschirm-Fixieren.
Bildschirm-Fixieren?
Dass es nicht dreht. Guck mal, das ist eines...
Ach so, ein Autorotor.
Jetzt hat es gedreht. Ja, jetzt heißt es aufreigeschaltet. Und wenn man das dann so wie bei Tweety so hochzieht...
Dann? Ach, dann ist es gelockt oder was?
Das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt, oder? Deine Gebete sind erhört worden. Das iPad hat...
Ich meine, jetzt nicht gleich das Thema wiederwechseln. Da muss ich erst mal eine Kapitelmarke setzen, mein Freund.
Gut, dann hast du es gesetzt.
Ja, immer an die Hörer denken.
Nee, noch nicht. Hier sind wir denn jetzt fertig mit Articles.
Wir sind ja noch überhaupt nicht beim iPad angekommen, aber wir können das definitiv noch aufnehmen. Also, lassen wir das jetzt sein hier mit Wikipedia-Applikationen?
Ja.
Wir sind uns nicht einig.
Genau. Wir waren jetzt auch bei SimpleTask und so weiter und so fort, und jetzt hatten wir hier noch so ein anderes Software-Dings da auf der Agenda. Software zum Problem lösen oder Rauchen aufhören. Diese Finanzgeschichten.
Ja, gehen wir doch mal in die Finanzwelt. Was hast du denn da entdeckt?
Naja, das, was wir alle schon entdeckt haben wahrscheinlich, ein Programm zum HBCI machen auf dem Mac. Da gibt es ja im Prinzip nur drei, die das können, und eins, was man visuell oder vom Interface ertragen könnte. Also, dir geht es jetzt um Banking, nicht um Finanz? Beides, Kombination von beidem. Also, ein Teil des Paketes ist sozusagen hier Managing gucken, wo welches Geld hingeht, wo man welches reinstecken kann und so weiter und so fort. Überblick behalten. Und das aber direkt natürlich mit dem Girokonto oder was auch immer gekoppelt, damit man halt nicht von Hand jetzt die Kontoauszüge abzippen muss, weil das geht ja nun mal auch nicht. So, und dann gibt es halt ein Stapel Software für das Planen und Verwalten von Finanzen. MoneyWells, Squirrel, iFinance, wie sie alle heißen.
Aber sind die nicht alle nur für die USA? Und man muss dann irgendwie 50 Dollar Upgrade zahlen, damit man aus dem Dollar ein Eurere machen kann?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Also die, die ich jetzt ausprobiert habe, das waren Squirrel und MoneyWell, die kommen auch mit Euro direkt klar.
Und die können auch das Datum in europäischer, das war ja immer das Problem.
Und jetzt habe ich halt dann dazu noch ein Software gesucht, die halt HWCI kann. Und da bin ich halt beim Saldo Martin gelandet.
Ja, den habe ich auch schon mal. Der ist großartig, oder?
Ja, es geht so. Also er ist okay. Für das, was drauf steht und so, ist es voll okay.
Das war dieses Tool, was dir in der Menüzeile deinen Kontostand anzeigt.
Genau.
Das ist aber, also so vom Setup und wie schnell man da zum Ergebnis kommt, dass man da tatsächlich mit HWCI spricht und so, das war erstaunlich schnell. Und das sieht nicht so scheiße aus wie iPhone.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Amerikanischen können alle kein HWCI?
Genau, da komme ich aber gleich noch zu. Moment. Du machst das ja spannend. Also der erste Schritt HWCI, um überhaupt erstmal in seine Bankdaten ranzukommen, ohne das selber abzutippen. Und das ist eben meiner Meinung nach das einzige Tool, was da taugt, Saldomat. Also es gibt noch zwei andere, aber die sehen auch aus, als wären sie gerade frisch zu Mac OS 10.0 in Carbon gestrickt worden und seitdem nie wieder angefasst. Also wirklich so...
Welche? Der Mann hat recht.
Eyebank.
Da braucht man sich gar nicht drum zu kümmern. Die sehen einfach scheiße aus. Wir kommen jetzt garantiert auch wieder in den Kommentaren, dass die ja total toll seien und sowas.
Eyebank?
Ja, ich glaube Eyebank heißt es.
Eyebank ist ja doch auch so voll Mac-like aus. Weißt du, vielleicht noch so was wie Mac-Konto. Also wir müssen jetzt auch erstmal ein bisschen unterscheiden, wovon wir jetzt eigentlich reden. Also es gibt so Online-Banking, dann gibt es irgendwie so Ausgabentricking, dann gibt es auch Buchhaltung.
Also momentan reden wir von der ersten Komponente überhaupt erstmal sozusagen Online-Banking, also mit deinem...
HBCI-Kline, so wie ich das jetzt auf meinem iPhone schon habe. Ich benutze iOutBank Pro.
Das habe ich auch. Genau.
Das ist auch sehr gut.
Ja, wie gesagt, auf Mac gibt es dann dafür eben so drei Ups. Zwei davon sehen mega scheiße aus.
Ja, aber welche sind das jetzt?
iBank und MacGyro heißt das andere. MacGyro ist so richtig so Carbon-Hölle. Ich glaube, ich glaube...
Ich glaube, iBank ist für HBCI.
Ich glaube, das könnte auch HBCI. Gucken wir nochmal kurz. Also ich habe halt da...
Aber warum hat dann dieser Saldomat einen Export nach iBank?
Stimmt nicht. Nein, Moment, das war ein anderes Programm. Das hieß aber auch so was mit Bank. Bank? Keine Ahnung. So, iBank ist eher auch so ein Verwaltungstool genau.
Verwaltungstool?
Ja, hier mit so Grafen malen über deine Ausgaben und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, wie hieß denn das andere HBCI-Mechprogramm?
Personal Small Business Financial Manager. Aber nimmt einem das denn eine Buchhaltung ab oder nicht?
Na, kommt doch deine Ansprüche an eine Buchhaltung an, glaube ich.
Nee, es kommt doch die Ansprüche des Finanzamts auf die Buchhaltung an. Meine Ansprüche, da würde der Tech-Editor ausreichen.
Also Bank X hieß es, Bank X. Bank X war das andere HBCI Tool.
Ach Bank X kann auch.
MacGyro.
Ach Bank X, das ist von Application Systems Heidelberg oder sowas, ne?
Ja und so sieht es auch aus.
Ja, das hat ich mir sogar mal gekauft, weil es damals das einzige war. Und das war ganz furchtbar. Also Überweisung konnte ich relativ von Anfang an nicht machen, weil meine Bank, weil ich gerne hier dieses SMS-Tan hätte, wie heißt das? Mtan. Und das unterstützt halt HBCI nicht. Und dann haben sie mir irgendwann mal mitgeteilt, nee, Postbank geht jetzt auch, kriegen wir jetzt auch keine Daten mehr runter, kannst dir aber ein Plugin für 50 Euro kaufen, mit dem das dann doch wieder geht. Und ich hab dann auch gedacht, also jetzt hab ich schon 50 Euro für das App ausgegeben und dann nochmal jetzt nachlegen, Bank X, das fand ich nicht toll.
Also ich muss...
Auf der Website steht, das heißt Bank Ten. B-E-N-K-Ten. Ah, jetzt hab ich mal das aussprechen.
Ja, das ist wirklich so... Und jetzt, um richtig runterzukommen, klickt ihr nochmal McGiro, kurz auf dein Screen. Wirklich, auch nochmal noch ne Stufe.
Homebanking für den Macintosh.
Da gibt's irgendwo, irgendwo gab's hier Screenshots oder mehr ausführliche Informationen finden sie hier und dann klickt mal da auf irgendwelche Screenshots und dann wird die ja so instantan schlecht.
Warte mal, ausführliche, was, wo ist das?
Nee, nee, in diesem Fleece-Text.
Das ist ja noch mit der Public Beta gemacht, die Screenshots. Also von der Meco ist der Public Beta.
Also, ist wirklich... Tim klappt gerade die Geräte.
Ach guck mal, die haben ja noch so richtig so ne Überweisungsvorlage drinne, die auch so aussieht wie ne Überweisungsvorlage.
Na das ist ja... Das ist ja nicht unbedingt schlecht.
Doch, das find ich total... Ich hab noch nie in meinem Leben ne echte Überweisungsvorlage gesehen. Oder ausgefüllt.
Was? Du lügst.
Ach, man kriegt doch jede Woche eine zugeschickt vom Verkehr.
Ja, mit denen kann ich aber nichts anfangen. Was soll ich mit denen machen? Ich geh ins Online-Banking, tippe das dann ab und dann...
MacGero hat Screenshots, die sie mit Meco S10... Was ist denn das? 10.2?
Das dürfte noch relativ am Anfang. Guck mal, das sind auch noch... Das war, als die Menüleiste auch so halb durchsichtig war.
Und das sieht sogar...
Die Fenster da ist dann...
Und mal ehrlich, guckt euch mal diesen... Guckt euch mal diesen...
War bestimmt mit Java gemacht. Aber guck mal, unten haben sie ein bisschen neuere Screenshots.
Stimmt, da haben sie versehentlich mal ein paar neue drangehängt. Aber nicht mal die anderen mal zwischendurch mal neun... Guck mal, die sind von 2004 offensichtlich.
Halt völlig indiskutabel. Hab ich mir so angeguckt, dachte mir, nee, geht gar nicht. Und deswegen bin ich jetzt bei den Saldomaten geworden.
Du hast jetzt mehr als nur die Screenshots angeschaut. Du hast es schon mal runtergegangen. Und es sieht dann auch so aus, wie auf den Screenshots.
Es sieht einfach alles total frickelig, nicht nach einer schicken, sexy Kokor-Up aus, sondern sieht nach...
Es geht halt auch um Finanzsäge.
Das Augebuch mit...
Na gut, also ich bin beim Saldomaten-Film...
Kannst du mal so eine Lifestyle-Zeitung rausbringen für das Finanzmanagement. Schöner buchen. Ja, dann gibt es irgendwie so Lipgloss für Überweisungsformulare und so weiter.
Im Test die schönsten Stifte zum rote Zahlen schreiben. Passt zum Blut, wenn man sich dann nach die Pulsadern aufsteilt.
Und noch so ein Wet-Floor-Effekt, da hast du so einen Aktienkurs, der nach oben geht und im Wet-Floor-Effekt geht er dann natürlich schon... So, also Saldomat war mein Tool, der war jetzt auf dem Mac. Auf dem iPhone habe ich mich damit noch gar nicht beschäftigt.
Nee, Saldomat ist super, finde ich auch. Also gerade dieses, wie oben die Uhrzeit oben den Kontostand stehen zu haben, ist schon cool.
Und Bescheid bekommen, wenn sich halt was getan hat. Gut, und das Zweite, dann war eben so eine Verwaltungssoftware, so Ausgabenmanagement und so weiter und so fort. Und da habe ich mir eben dieses iBank, das Quirrel...
Also Saldomat ist jetzt dein Tool, mit dem du HWCI machst?
Genau.
Okay, gut.
Kostet irgendwie so 10 Euro oder sowas. Kann man echt mal gut ausgeben. Funktioniert auch so für sich schon allein ziemlich gut, dass man einfach mal mitkriegt, wenn was vom Konto abgeht oder drauf geht.
So und Saldomat halt eben als Feature so Export in alle möglichen Ausgaben, Tracking-Management-Tools und auch in dieses eine Invoice schreiben.
Also hast du jetzt alle Tools getestet, die HWCI können? Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Ich habe alle dreimal installiert und alle dreimal gestartet und alle dreimal connected. Und bei den ersten beiden, also BankX und MacGyro, hatte ich eigentlich schon gar keine Lust mehr, irgendwas noch weiter damit zu tun. Und beim Saldo Martin dachte ich, na okay, das geht ja noch.
Und was ist der Unterschied zwischen der normalen und der Pro-Version da?
Na, bei der Pro-Version hast du halt noch so, kannst du deine, also du kriegst halt diese Transaktionsliste ja immer vom Saldo Martin so von deinem Konto, halt Kontoauszüge, Kontostand und so weiter. Und bei der Pro-Version kannst du da drauf halt dann noch Filter setzen und irgendwie deine Ausgabe halt noch zusammenfiltern und organisieren und automatisieren, keine Ahnung. Also ich benutze das tatsächlich jetzt eben nur als Slave, um an meine Transaktion zu kommen, um die dann in...
Andere Tools rein zu importieren.
Genau.
Was heißt iBank oder MoneyWale werden jetzt hier die Tools, weil was anderes gibt nicht?
Na, Squirrel gibt es noch.
Das kann er auch da rein kriegen. Das steht aber hier so explizit nicht.
Also ich habe hier eine Beta-Bär, ich habe sie installiert und ich kann mal gucken, was der so alles kann.
Also es gibt iBank, MoneyWale, iFinance, Squirrel, das ist hier als New und Grand Total. Ah, verstehe, alles klar. Also der Saldomat ist sozusagen das fehlende Plugin für Euro, HWCI-Banking für Programme, die an sich ganz cool sind, aber eben nur Amerika im Blick haben, von daher von HWCI nichts wissen.
Und bei welchem Programm bist du dann gelandet?
Ja, genau. Der nächste Schritt war dann eben genau diese Zweitsoftware, und da hab ich echt auch alle installiert und alle ausprobiert und war ein bisschen schockiert, dass die alle eigentlich zwar so ein bisschen fancy aussehen, aber im Grunde ganz schön schlecht gebaut sind. Das ist so, man hat so den Eindruck, da sitzt halt, die Firma heißt zwar Major Cool Software Cooperation, aber am Ende hat man den Eindruck, da sitzt nur einer. Also so eine Ein-Personen-Geschichte, das ist irgendwie bei allen so. Und so ganz...
Der Banking ganz lustig findet.
Ja, und da sind so ganz komische Bugs drin und irgendwie so, du kämpfst erstmal die erste halbe Stunde mit der Software, um so diesen Stand hinzukriegen, wie man ihn so erwarten würde. Also du holst dir von Saldomat halt deine aktuelle Balance und alle Transaktionen und frumpst die da rein und gehst jetzt davon aus, dass die Summe oder die Zahl, die da beim Saldomaten steht...
Das Problem hatte ich ja genau so.
Also es sind halt so ganz komische Sachen, oder? Dann bieten sie halt alle möglichen Features so mit irgendwie, du hast jetzt Budgets und Eimer oder Kategorien, wo halt deine Transaktionen so getaggt werden, ne? Das heißt, du hast halt irgendwie ganz eben, immer wenn am Geldautomaten so, dann sind das jetzt hier Geldautomaten-Transaktionen und so. Und dabei passieren dann so richtig, so richtig böse Bugs, dass dann irgendwie die Transaktionen aus der ganzen Liste verschwinden und dann nur noch in der einen Kategorie auftauchen, aber auch aus der Totalsumme verschwinden und so. Also wo ich mir dachte, Jungs, also jetzt, ich wollte... Es geht ums Geld. Ich wollte das Problem nicht verschlimmern, ja? Irgendwie verbessern, so. Also war ich echt ein bisschen schockiert, oder? So viel Software, die auf Anhieb gut aussieht, aber eben dann doch gar nicht so viel kann und so.
Also ich hab mich damals nach langen Hin und Her dann für Moneywell entschieden, keine Ahnung warum.
Ich im Übrigen auch.
Hab das dann gekauft und das hat sich nachhinein als ziemlicher Pferdefuß erwiesen. Und zwar ist das so, man kann das aus Saldomat alles exportieren und dann in Moneywell, aber ich glaube, das haben sie alle, importieren. Und der importiert jedes Mal alles.
Nee, das ist jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr so.
Das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so. Dann muss ich es mal wieder ausprobieren. Das war ganz furchtbar. Ich habe das irgendwie gehabt. Weil das ist ja nicht so, dass man irgendwie eine Liste kriegt, mit was es heute passiert und dann hat man einen Stichtag, sondern es kann ja auch sein, dass eine Buchung durchaus drei Tage in der Vergangenheit ist. Warum auch immer. Und dann hat der immer alles doppelt gebucht.
Also ich habe jetzt auch Moneywell als, erstmal für die 30-Tage-Testlizenz als Primärprogramm ausgewählt, weil das noch so am besten daher kam von allen anderen. Und da ist es jetzt so, du sagst dem Saldomaten halt, konfigurierst du, ich will nach Moneywell exportieren. Und dann, wenn du das erste Mal exportierst, zieht er dir alles in das Moneywell rein, was du bisher da im Saldomaten auch gekriegt hast. Und wenn du das nächste Mal klickst, dann kriegst du nur die letzten 10 sozusagen. Und dann checkt Moneywell aber automatisch, wenn da welche doppelt drin sind und zeigt dir das an. Achtung, hier sind Duplicates drin. Soll ich die mergen und dann merge ich die. Also sie haben sozusagen dieses Handling von Saldomat. Gibt mir jetzt mehr als ich eigentlich bräuchte. Detektet das, dass da jetzt ein paar Overlappings sind und merge ich die dann gleich. Das ist irgendwie schon gut. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist Moneywell halt auch so ein Programm, wo man echt erst mal drei Versuche braucht, um so zu verstehen, wie das funktioniert. Ich probiere es jetzt mal noch. Ich habe es jetzt irgendwie so zwei Wochen schon am Klicken. Ich bin jetzt so einigermaßen warm mit geworden und habe jetzt auch meine Ausgaben und Einnahmen und so alles schön geteckt. Das funktioniert auch gut und er erkennt auch automatisch, wenn jetzt hier neue Abbuchungen von iTunes oder so kommen, dann teckt er die und packt die in den richtigen Eimer und so. Das ist schon alles ganz gut. Ich bin aber irgendwie aufgrund der Erfahrung auch mit den anderen Applikationen schon immer so dabei, jedes Mal, wenn ich das benutze, kopiere ich mir, also mache ich mir erstmal einen Backup von dieser MoneyWell-Datei. Weil beim Ausprobieren auch von MoneyWell hatte ich so halt bei den ersten zwei Versuchen, mir das irgendwie so zerschrottet, dass es auch nicht mehr wieder...
Stimmt, man muss auch beim Import, muss man hier angeben, in welchem Format liegt denn jetzt das Datum vor und sowas?
Das muss man halt ihm auch das erste Mal sagen, was ich aber ganz gut finde. Die benutzen halt so eine Austauschdatei. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt das, QIX oder irgendwie so. Und da können halt alle möglichen Datumsformate drin stehen. Und er sagt dir das halt immer hin und du kannst das halt auswählen. Das sind ja nur vier Dinge zum Auswählen, wie das Format sein könnte. Und danach checkt er das auch richtig. Also auch, das musst du nur einmal machen.
Sie kriegen Fließkommazahlen nur so halb hin.
So, und jetzt habe ich, bei MoneyWell ist halt noch die Sache. In dem Forum habe ich halt mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt und da schreien halt extrem viele Leute HBCI, HBCI, hier European Customers, wir würden alle kaufen und macht doch mal HBCI. Und das haben sie jetzt wohl auch auf ihre Top Priority Feature Liste tatsächlich gesetzt.
Bei MoneyWell.
Und bei den anderen habe ich da dererlei noch nichts vernommen. Also es ist nicht auszuschließen, dass da auch in, oder es ist ziemlich wahrscheinlich, dass du...
Haben die denn auch eine deutsche Oberfläche eigentlich? Oder benutzt du das wahrscheinlich auch alles auf Englisch?
Ja, ich habe ja mein OS und alles auf Englisch. Von daher benutze ich das da auch auf Englisch. Ich meine, bei Finanzen wäre es ganz hilfreich.
Genau, es gibt nämlich so... Manchmal gibt es so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, da würde ich jetzt auch gerne mal... Geht das eigentlich bei Mac OS X, dass man für ein Programm sagen kann, mit welcher Sprache es hochkommen soll?
Nicht dass ich wüsste.
Wie, mit welcher Sprache es hochkommen soll?
Ich, genauso wie ihr wahrscheinlich, installiere eigentlich alles auf Englisch, weil ich einfach bei vielen Programmen kriege ich einfach... Ja, das ist schon schön, Augenkrebs. Weil mir die Art, also ich verstehe dann einfach nicht, wovon die Rede ist. Abgesehen davon will man halt mal schnell Hilfe finden im Internet und du weißt, wie groß der Anteil der Hilfe im Internet auf Englisch und Deutsch ist und so, wie auch immer. Dann gibt es aber so manche Programme, die möchte ich halt ganz gerne auf Deutsch benutzen. Und da gehören so Sachen, wo so lokal-kolorit-Fachbegriffe am Start sind. Bank definitiv dazu. Würde ich halt gerne eine Möglichkeit haben, zu sagen, dieses Programm, bitte, wenn es gestartet wird, soll einfach eine andere Sprachreihenfolge vom OS erhalten.
Ja klar gibt es das, wusstest du das nicht? Apfel-i?
Und dann?
Und dann ist eine Liste mit allen Sprachen installiert, so kannst du die abwählen, die du nicht haben möchtest.
Nicht dein Ernst.
Nee, ist der Paul, der hat nur die Mütze vom Ernst auf. Der ist leider...
Apfel-i, wo?
Auf so was Programm.
Ja, und dann?
Dann steht da unten Sprachen oder sowas. Ich muss jetzt mal gucken. Wenn es mehrere Sprachen hat. Warte mal.
Wie wenn es mehrere Sprachen hat.
Na ja, so iPhoto oder sowas.
Aber Firefox hat zum Beispiel nicht mehrere Sprachen hier bei mir.
Ja, Firefox hat ja auch. Firefox muss natürlich auch mal in der richtigen Sprache runterladen.
Also diese Sprachen, da träumst du jetzt gerade von irgendwas.
Also bei Safari hab ich auch nicht.
Ich wüsste nicht, vielleicht beim Developen irgendwie.
Nee, die haben sie rausgeschmissen. Da gab's wieder die Sprachpakete und die konnte man so rausschmeißen und reinpappen.
Der Chat meint auch irgendwie Apfel-I auf das Ab, aber ich wüsste nicht wo, ehrlich gesagt. Aber es gibt hier ein Programm. Haha, der Chat ist hilfreich. Language-Switcher. Use your apps in different languages at the same time. Guck an. Da kann man das genau machen.
Waren die das denn rausgeschmissen mit den Sprachpaketen?
Ich weiß nicht. Wann war das denn drin?
Das haben sie wahrscheinlich zu Snowlappert rausgeschmissen, weil sie jetzt ja eh alle so zusammen compilen.
Das war von 10.1 bis irgendwas. Da war da so eine ganz lange Liste drin. Da konnte man auch einzelne Sprachpakete rausschmeißen. Das war am Anfang auch immer, wenn man irgendwie so eine Sprache hatte, das war mir zu groß, konnte man Japanisch rausschmeißen, Chinesisch und so ein Zeug.
Aber hier gerade, es gibt ein Tool. Entschuldigung, dass ich von dem ganzen Finanzthema jetzt abgelenkt habe, wir kommen da gleich nochmal drauf. Aber es gibt language-switcher.app. Das verspricht genau das zu tun. Das wäre ja toll.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich schlimmer finden sollte, dass ihr das nicht wusste, dass es jemals gab.
Ich hab irgendwie so eine Erinnerung, aber ich kann mich schon lange nicht mehr daran erinnern, das mal gesehen zu haben. Von daher war ich mir jetzt gar nicht nur so sicher, wo das überhaupt war. Jetzt schaut sich hier dieser Language-Switcher mit so einem schönen Progress-Bar und scannt jetzt wahrscheinlich meine Ups. Dann bietet er mir die Möglichkeit an, für jedes Programm zu sagen, mit was das hochkommen soll. Fancy.
Und jetzt hier live, irgendwie live und in Farbe.
Das ist das Schöne an solchen community-gestützten Live-Sendungen.
Community-gestützte Live-Sendungen.
Ja, ist es doch hier.
Also bis 10.05. gab es das, kann ich bestätigen, sagt es hier im Chat. Und das würde ich halt auch vermuten. Also ich meine, bei 10.06. haben sie auch diese komischen Abbandels runtergeschrumpft in der Größe. Und irgendwelche Sachen da zusammengepackt. Und da wären wahrscheinlich genau die Sprachpakete. Das war doch genau das, das hat doch Dennis erzählt. Bilde ich mir ein. Übrigens, Dennis. Könntest du auch mal was sagen?
Wir sollten das Gaffa-Tip abmachen.
Vorhin auch so.
Talking about Community Support.
Das ging dann wirklich nicht.
Also jetzt heißt unsere Sendung auch wieder MM044 da auf dem Stream. Aha, okay, gut 300 Leute hören sich gerade unsere Ausführungen zu Finanzsoftware an. Dann bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Thema, wenn das so interessant ist. Nee, ich find das ja ganz spannend. Also bist du denn jetzt fertig da mit deinem Money Well? Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ganz verstanden, was jetzt eigentlich der Scope ist von diesem Tool.
Na, der Scope ist, also ich hab tatsächlich...
Ähnlich wie bei diesen ToDo-Listen. In Hoffnung, was in Griff zu kriegen, was nicht in Griff zu kriegen ist.
Nee, nee, nee, ich hab einfach so... Ich bin nicht so ein Kontoauszugsleser und so ein Auseinanderklamüserer, sondern ich will irgendwie das aufbereitet haben. Ich will irgendwie sagen, gib mir die letzten Transaktionen, sortier die gleich in die Kategorien ein, mal mir Grafen, wo Ausgaben und Eingaben getrennt sind, und dann will ich da auf die Grafen klicken und sagen, wo kommen jetzt hier die ganzen Kosten her? Einfach so ein bisschen eigenes Budget-Analysen. Und das funktioniert mit MoneyWell, finde ich, ziemlich gut, weil du siehst dann halt so deine Eingabenausnahmen, Grafen für die Monate, dann klickst du auf den Monat, und dann zeigt er dir links in dieser Einmalliste an, irgendwie so und so viel Geld aus einem Geldautomaten gezogen, so und so viel Geld irgendwie für Drogen.
Dafür finde ich ehrlich gesagt Saldomat ganz geil, weil Saldomat gibt mir dieses Gefühl, dass mein Konto, also vorher kannte ich mein Konto in zwei Zuständen. Voll, wenn Geld drauf war, und leer, wenn der Automat nichts mehr rausgespuckt hat. Und jetzt so dieses Saldomat hat jetzt bei mir so dieses Gefühl dafür im Laufe der Zeit geweckt, da gibt es auch noch einen Zwischenzustand, wo sich das so nach und nach leert. Und das ist eigentlich ganz geil.
Genau, was ich auch noch mit MoneyWell erreichen wollte, war zu sehen, wie viel Geld müsste ich denn eigentlich sozusagen jeden Monat zur Verfügung haben, wenn ich jetzt miete, Strom und alles, was mir bekannt ist, was regelmäßig kommt. Und das dann einfach so über die Monate schon mal so aufbereitet und dann jeden Monat sehen, okay, jetzt habe ich dies, das und jenes schon ausgegeben und habe jetzt noch so und so viel prinzipiell auf der Kralle. Weil irgendwie, man verliert da ja schon so den Überblick. Und da bin ich jetzt, bis auf diese kleinen Macken am Anfang, irgendwie doch recht zufrieden mit diesem MoneyWell.
MoneyWell only available in English, sagt mein Linguistwitcher. Na, tolle Wurst.
Saldomat hat übrigens sogar so einen kleinen RSS-Server drinne. Der sieht zwar leider total scheiße aus, aber der ist...
RSS-Server?
Ja, wenn du NetNewsware nutzt, also wenn du auf deinem Rechner einen RSS-Reader hast, dann kannst du dir deine Kontoausgaben als RSS-Feed und deinen Newsreader reinbauen.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen gaga, finde ich ja schon, aber es geht ja.
Also legt die Datei irgendwo ab, oder er hat einen Webserver.
Aber du kannst ja halt auch so Growl-Notifications und alles, also der ist schon echt so, ist schon so ein kleines Schweizer Taschenmesser für deinen HWCI, das ist schon...
Das fände ich immer besonders toll, weil ich hab mal an die Postbank eine lange Mail geschrieben, so von wegen, wieso bietet ihr eigentlich kein RSS-Feed an? Womit ich als Antwort höchstens mitgerechnet hätte. Dann haben sie mir aber eine lange, ausführliche Begründung gegeben, dass das ja nicht geht und weiß ja toll was, warum nicht. Und weil sie, egal, also ist jetzt nicht so wichtig warum, aber sie haben sich offensichtlich mit dem Thema tatsächlich beschäftigt. Aber mein Traum war immer zu haben, dass man hier, dass man RSS-Feed, dass ich meine Kontoausgaben im NetNews war ja sehr.
Noch mal kurz eine Nachfrage zu dem ganzen Finanzkram. Also wenn ich dich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, du hast ja der HBCI-Software angeschaut und das Einzige, was ruhig geblieben ist, ist Saldomat. Dann hast du dir irgendwie diese ganzen Personal Finance Manager, die dir halt im Wesentlichen so erklären sollen, wo dein ganzes Geld geblieben ist. Oder wo es herkommt, du hast es irgendwie beim Kaisers gelassen oder irgendwie bei deiner Telefonfirma oder Supermarkt oder Amazon oder Porno Kino, wo man halt seine Kohle so los wird. Und da ist dann MoneyWell deine erste Wahl, weil die anderen alle irgendwie Dinge vergessen haben.
Weil die noch schlechter waren als MoneyWell. Also MoneyWell ist noch nicht fertig. Noch lange nicht, aber es ist benutzbarer als alle anderen. Also es ist noch nicht so der Traum, dass die dir so diese shiny Screenshots mit Wet-Floor-Effekt und irgendwie schicker, slicker, Cocoa-Grafik suggerieren wollen. Du denkst so, boah, das sieht ja nach einer Hammer-Up aus. Aber wenn du dann doch rumklickst, merkst du halt, es ist noch nicht ganz fertig. Aber von diesen, also iBank, Squirrel und MoneyWell, finde ich MoneyWell einfach am benutzbarsten noch.
Ist klar. Ich würde mal hier den Salto-Mat mal in Betrieb nehmen.
Es gibt doch in Amerika ist doch dieses Mint ganz beliebt. Ja, das gibt es leider nicht für Deutschland. Mit T. Also mint.com. Die sind jetzt von Quicken gerade aufgekauft worden. Das ist eine reine Online-Lösung.
Ich dachte, das wäre so eine Web-Statistik-Tour gewesen.
Nee, Mint ist heavament.com. Das soll einem dann wunderbar alles aufarbeiten. Den gibst du direkt deine Bankdaten. Dann holt ihr das immer schön rein und arbeitet das für dich auf. Und die sind wohl jetzt dabei, dass gerade auch...
Die Bank greifen auf mein Konto zu.
Na, die haben halt den HBCI-Client dann für dich drin.
Übrigens, noch eine kleine Erwähnung. Im Chat kam es nämlich auch gerade. Es gibt auch eine Open-Source-Apple- oder Mac-Software, die heißt Pecunia. Nee, P-E-C-U-N-I-A. Und da kann man halt auch so ein bisschen HBCI machen. Und so ist aber 0.2 Open-Source-Software. Und dementsprechend sollte man auch seine Erwartungshaltung anpassen.
Du hast das mal ausprobiert, ja?
Ich hab das auch mal geklickt.
Es zeigt was an.
Es zeigt was an, genau.
Weil es für eine Banking-Software schon mal relativ okay ist. Also wie gesagt, bei BankX wäre ich mittlerweile dankbar, wenn sie was anzeigen würden.
Und hier auf dem...
Ist das hier dieses itcompetence.de oder was?
pecuniapanking.de Genau.
Ich hab das in den Google-Uhr so offen, und dann hast du ja das rausgeschmissen.
Ich kann dir das mal zum Klicken einfach hier...
Werden sie live dabei, wenn wir Tim weiter das Internet erklären. Im nächsten Kapitel E-Mail.
Ja, naja, so weit erstmal meine Fauschung. Also es gibt da bestimmt auch noch...
Na ja, sieht jetzt aber auch nicht vollkommen daneben aus.
Also es ist schon, es ist schon okay. Aber ich...
Sie könnten durchaus auf dem richtigen Weg sein.
Aber es ist eben Richtung Haushaltsrechnung entwickelt werden, heißt es hier. Ja, und du kannst da halt auch Überweisungen machen und so. Das ist an sich schon mal ganz gut.
Das geht auch mit Saldomat?
Ne, das ist so rein das Anzeigeteil.
Ach echt?
Man kann damit nicht überweisen?
Genau. Saldomat ist eher so die Get-Richtung. Also du kriegst halt alles, alle Daten und kannst sie halt irgendwo reinpipen und anzeigen und filtern und bridgen und sonst irgendwas. Aber das ist jetzt nicht zum...
Wobei, für die Überweisung selber bin ich ja mit der, also bin ja Postbank-Kunde noch und mit deren Web-Interface war ich immer sehr, sehr glücklich. Die geben sich echt mit.
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch kein Problem mit Überweisung und Web-Interface. Ich habe Saldomat, wie gesagt, eher als Sklaven, um das in andere Software reinzubridgen oder eben spontan mal zu sehen, was denn Sache ist, ohne jetzt wieder den Key und das Passwort und alles mögliche.
Ja gut, das fände ich auch ganz gut. Aber dieses iOutBank Pro, das kann ja sogar auf dem iPhone Überweisungen machen.
Wie heißt das?
Das Name ist ganz furchtbar, aber das Icon ist zumindest nicht mehr scheiße.
Das muss ich mir auch...
Ein Wort iOutBank und dann Pro.
iOutBank reicht total, wenn du nur ein Konto hast, erst mal. Also das gibt dieses iOutBank, ich glaube, das ist kostenlos, und iOutBank Pro, wenn man sich nicht alles täuscht.
Ist das so?
Noch mal hier, GSM, das ist heul.
Ich hab das... Das kostet 10 Dollar, irgendwie 10 Euro und das ist irgendwie prima. Also am Anfang war es noch ein bisschen merkwürdig im User-Interface, da haben sie aber enorm nachgezogen und mittlerweile kommt das schon sehr iPhone-isch und sehr elegant daher, also kann ich nur sehr empfehlen. Unser großer Finanzberatungsblock bei Mobile Max.
Investieren Sie jetzt in den Mobile Max-Fonds mit größten Renditechancen jetzt hier.
Ich hab da noch so eine Mail bekommen von so einem Insider, dass ich ruhig hier Geld anlegen soll.
Okay, jetzt können wir aber das Thema Finanzen auch mal beenden, oder? Ja, womit wollen wir weitermachen? Also jetzt sind wir gerade so schön bei Software. Ich finde das mal ganz gut, weil wir das irgendwie schon so lange nicht mehr gemacht haben. Ich kann es nur kurz andeuten, weil es mir bei Herrn Grober über den Weg gelaufen ist und auch nochmal ein interessanter Ansatz ist. Ich habe es noch nicht getestet.
Was denn?
Das heißt Crashplan. Und es ist ein weiterer…
Ich dachte, das wäre das Thema, wenn wir keine Themen mehr haben sollten mit meiner Sendung.
Was, Crashplan? Na, ich kann da jetzt nicht viel zu sagen. Ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen. Also das ist halt ein weiterer Contender in dieser ganzen… Du willst deine Daten immer sicher haben und unter Umständen dabei auch das Internet benutzen, so wie Dropbox das ja auch im Prinzip macht. Und Crashplan allerdings ist jetzt insofern ganz interessant. Wie gesagt, ich kann noch nichts darüber sagen, wie gut das tatsächlich funktioniert. Ich fand bloß jetzt von der Beschreibung her die Sache erwähnenswert. Crashplan ist eine Software, die du installierst und die macht halt ein vollständiges Backup von deinem Rechner auf einen anderen Rechner, zum Beispiel auch in deinem Laden. Das heißt, er macht jetzt überhaupt erst mal so zwei Computer und dann backt er irgendwie ab und dann hast du da halt ein Backup. Du kannst das aber auch auf einen anderen Computer, der auch woanders steht, über das Internet machen. Und du kannst das aber auch auf anderer Leute Computer machen. Also du könntest dein Backup auf meinen Computer machen. Das ist verschlüsselt. Und du kannst sozusagen anderen anbieten, dass sie bei dir Backup hinterlassen. Oder du kannst sagen, was weiß ich, Cross-Backup machen. Also ein sehr interessanter Ansatz.
Scheint es für alle Plattformen zu geben.
Gibt es für alle Plattformen. Und vor allem bieten sie dann darüber hinaus natürlich auch noch die Cloud an, sodass du eben dein Backup auch da bei ihnen im Netz abwürfst. Und ja, da würde mich auch Feedback interessieren von Leuten, die das vielleicht schon zum Einsatz gebracht haben. Ich bin, wie gesagt, noch nicht dazu gekommen. Finde aber gerade diesen Gedanken mit gegenseitig deine eigenen Rechner untereinander Backup ganz interessant. Also das will man dann nur hoffen, dass er dann bei dem, wenn man das Backup von dem einen Rechner auf einem Rechner hat und der davon dann auch noch ein Backup macht, dass er nicht dann nochmal das Backup von dem anderen auch nochmal mit Backup, das wäre dann ein bisschen bekloppt.
Aber das könnte man ja im Prinzip auch mit Time Machine sich so einrichten, also so, oder? Auf Mac, Apple Talk, also AFP-Network?
Time Machine geht nicht übers Internet. So, und ich habe jetzt hier zum Beispiel Studio und zu Hause und so, und was ist mit Mobil? Und du willst ja auch immer irgendwie Backups auch über das Netz machen können. Und über Internet, das hat halt Apple überhaupt nicht drin. Das kann man sich mal angucken, und vielleicht gibt es ja da irgendwelche Ergebnisse.
Aber ich finde jetzt hier ein Jahr für 54 Dollar finde ich jetzt auch nicht übertrieben viel, dass man das dann irgendwo ins Netz einfach.
Du kannst ja schon zwei Mobile Me verkaufen. Ein halbes Mobile Me verkaufen, meine ich. Genau.
Ich habe ja hier letztens diesen...
Ja eben, also es kostet die Hälfte vom Mobile Me und tut etwas, was Mobile Me nicht tut.
Ich habe ja hier letztens, außer lauter Langeweile, mal diesen Talk von Herrn Gruber auf der Macworld 2010 gesehen. The Gruber 10 hieß der hier oder so, oder?
Ja, die zehn Probleme.
Da hat er ja auch irgendwie hier über Mobile Me so ein bisschen gerantet, fand ich auch ganz sinnvoll eigentlich. Erstens, wozu sie eigentlich diese Web-Ups da haben. So, what's the point? Und dann halt, dass iDisk einfach auch so schlecht ist im Vergleich zu Dropbox, was ein Free Service ist und so weiter. Und dann noch 99 Dollar dafür im Jahr und irgendwie ein kompletter Fail irgendwie. Benutzen das Leute?
Ja, ich kann mich jetzt auch nur noch wiederholen mit Sync. Also, Sync ist ein ungelöstes Problem und die Firma, die das löst, wird da eine Menge von haben. So, und ich erwarte einfach von Apple, dass sie dieses Problem lösen. Also, es kann einfach nicht sein, dass ich zwei Computer von ihnen kaufe und dass diese Geräte nicht universell auf allen möglichen Ebenen im Hinblick auf Document-Sharing, auf Hinblick auf Backup, auf Hinblick auf jeden Scheiß, die in der Lage sind, sich einfach gegenseitig die Daten zukommen zu lassen. Und zwar automatisch ohne irgendeinen Button-Click, außer vielleicht einem am Anfang. So, und das muss einfach immer gehen. Das hat einfach zu gehen. Aber I'll repeat myself. So, Spiele.
Spiele? Was soll das Thema Spiele sein?
Na ja, es ist jetzt auch schon nicht mehr brandneue Information, aber da gibt es ja eine interessante Entwicklung. Die Firma Valve betreibt eine Plattform, die heißt Steam. Und offensichtlich können nur so die Hard-Mac-User wie ich das Ganze so seelenfern von sich geben, weil für alle anderen ist das wohl volle Realität, weil man ja irgendwie unter Windows, ne? Da wird man halt, ne?
Also jeder, der sozusagen im hohen Alter noch zockt, also alles über Schulalter, der kennt auf jeden Fall Steam.
Du hast damit schon mal gearbeitet?
Ne, als ich im Schulalter war, hatte ich, mach mal den Deckel von der Marter, dann klappt es auch mit dem Trinken. Man freut sich, dass das so laut ist. Ne, also zu Schulzeiten habe ich natürlich auch hier mal so Counter-Strike gezockt und so. Und da fingen das mit diesem Steam an. Das bedeutete, man musste halt zu seinem Half-Life und seinem Counter-Strike noch so eine Steam-Software installieren, die dann auch so unten in der Taskbar die ganze Zeit immer lief. Da hatte man so einen Online-Account und da drüber konnte man sich sozusagen in so Kanäle einklinken. Und da gab es halt Counter-Strike-Channels. Und da hat man sich dann sozusagen zu spielen verabredet oder konnte einen Counter-Strike-Spieleserver auswählen usw. Also früher war das ja in-game. Das heißt, dass in Counter-Strike irgendwie, konntest du dir dann die Server aussuchen, auf denen du jetzt spielen möchtest. Und das haben sie dann in dieses Steam rein verlagert. Und dann kamen halt über die Zeit immer mehr Spiele da hinzu, die sie über dieses Steam abgewickelt haben. Bis hin dazu, dass eben auch andere Spielehersteller, also nicht nur Valve, da drüber Spiele gepublished oder halt dafür gesorgt haben, dass die halt aktiviert werden. Also ich glaube heutzutage ist es so, ich habe halt lange nicht mehr Steam benutzt oder so gespielt. Aber ich glaube heutzutage muss auch die Spiele, wenn du sie kaufst und das erste Mal reinsteckst, musst du sie auch über diesen Steam-Account aktivieren. Das heißt, du kaufst ja ein neues Spiel, hast noch keinen Account, musst sie erst mal bei Steam anmelden, Account machen und dann darfst du erst spielen. Und ja, das, was Valve jetzt angekündigt hat, ist das eben für Mac rauszubringen. Und sie wollen dann halt auch einen Stapel eigener Spiele dann da gleich mit anbieten. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt alle Spiele, die auf Windows, Steam laufen, auch automatisch auf Mac verfügbar sind. Sondern du musst dann schon für den Mac angepasste Versionen von deinen Spielen natürlich in dieses Steam publishen. Und sie haben gesagt, glaube ich, dass sie ihr Half-Life und Counter-Strike halt die OpenGL-Version jetzt da anbieten, dass die da spielbar sind. Also es ist für Zocker, die auf Mac zocken wollen, schon eine gute Nachricht. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt auf einmal ein Riesentor an Spielen verfügbar ist.
Das heißt, auch Macintosh-User können dann lernen, wie sie ihre Lehrer und Mitschüler umbringen.
Endlich, endlich. Oder du kannst ja bei Counter-Strike auch Counter-Terrorist spielen, ne? Also du kannst ja auch den spielen, der jetzt sozusagen die Amokläufer verhindert.
Ich hab noch nie in meinem Leben Counter-Strike gespielt.
Früher hab ich das tatsächlich auch. Also das ist so ein Spiel, da kann man unzählige Zeit vorverbringen.
Das ist ja das erste, was kommt, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe. Portal, dieses Programm.
Ich bin da so ein bisschen raus, ehrlich gesagt.
Portal, ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, wenn ihr glaubt, dass ich vom Thema Windows keine Ahnung hätte, dann gibt das jetzt mal. Portal ist glaube ich, da hast du so ein Werkzeug, also eine deiner Waffen ist, du kannst Löcher in die Wand machen, quasi in eine andere Dimension, also die dann unter Umständen in den selben Raum wiederfühlen, aber du kommst an einer anderen Stelle raus.
Du springst in Löcher rein, ja?
Genau, das muss irgendwie ganz knuffig sein wohl.
Ach, das ist alles. Man springt nur rum durch Löcher?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das nur macht.
Ohne Schießen jetzt? Was ist das für ein Spiel?
Action Adventure heißt die Kategorie. Ach, da muss man jetzt keinen erschießen. Ich dachte, das ist so das Spiel, wo man alle erschießen muss immer. Was die Firma macht. Also Half-Life und so weiter, das ist doch auch alles mit Monster erschießen und Leute erschießen.
Und bei Counter-Strike kannst du aber auch gewinnen ohne zu schießen. Echt? Aber das macht doch keiner. Nee. Ihr habt beide noch nie Counter-Strike gespielt, oder was?
Nee, Counter-Strike haben wir noch nie gespielt.
Das ist halt so, ein kurzer Überblick über Counter-Strike. Also früher, ich hab's ja ewig auch nicht mal gespielt, aber früher war das so, du hast so eine Karte oder verschiedene Levels und in jedem Level geht es darum, die Terroristen haben halt so eine Bombe. So der erste Terrorist, der dem Spiel joint, der hat halt die Bombe so und läuft halt so rum und die Terroristen müssen halt jetzt irgendwo bei den Counter-Terroristen in der Basis oder irgendwo an, was weiß ich, irgendwo eine Bombe platzieren und die muss dann hochgehen. Dann haben die Terroristen gewonnen und die Counter-Terroristen, also die andere Gruppe in diesem Spiel dann, die muss halt verhindern, dass diese Bombe hochgeht, also sozusagen die vorher entschärfen oder alle Terroristen umbringen oder sowas. Das heißt, du kannst ein Spiel gewinnen als Terrorist, in dem du einfach die Bombe platzierst und verhinderst, dass die da, also stellst dich einfach vor die Bombe und die anderen kommen dir durch und können sie nicht entschärfen, ja, so ohne Töten. Oder als Counter-Terrorist, kannst du da auch gewinnen ohne Töten? Schwierig, also wenn du, ja, nee, muss schon, also ist schon mit Schießen.
Also ich hab früher immer ganz...
Definitiv ist das so zielführender als alles andere. Dann gehts halt los, ne? Also du hast ja auch pro Level so eine bestimmte Zeit nur und dann spielst du unendlich viele Instanzen, also es gilt irgendwie, am Tag spielst du 500 diese Bombenentschärfen oder Bombenleger-Töten-Spiele und in verschiedensten Levels und hast da so ein Potpourri an Waffen und ja.
Ich fand Unreal Tournament ganz geil, das hab ich sehr viel gespielt. Das war auch mit tendenziell mehr Schießen.
Also was bedeutet das jetzt? Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe...
Wir wollen Counter-Strike spielen.
Es ist davon auszugehen, dass Valve einen Großteil seiner nicht unerfolgreichen Spiele auf den Mac portiert, aber auf jeden Fall portieren sie Steam und das würden sie ja nicht tun, wenn sie nicht auch vorhaben, mehr als ein Programm zu portieren und das öffnet theoretisch dann auch noch Dritten den doch recht erfolgreichen Distributionsweg von Steam. außerdem, ja, das dürfte natürlich dann auch sehr interessante Vergleichsmöglichkeiten bieten, was so die Performance der Maschinen und insbesondere der OpenGL-Treiber so betrifft. Da bin ich dann ehrlich gesagt am gespanntesten darauf. Aber es ist natürlich auch eine Grundaussage über die Zukunft der Mac-Plattform. Weil das, ich meine, das ist ja auch, ich will ja nicht sagen, dass jetzt Mac-Leute nicht spielen, aber es ist halt so, wenn man gerne spielt, dann ist das ein erheblicher Grund gewesen, sich dann eben doch für Windows zu entscheiden und Macintosh einfach links liegen zu lassen, weil man dann einfach da nicht auch nur im Ansatz dieselbe Auswahl an Baller und sonst wie Prinzessinnen gespielt hat.
Es gibt da aber auch so, das ist halt so einfach, weil es gibt halt auch noch bei den Zockern die Konsolenfraktion und die sind losgelöst von ihrem Rechner. Die spielen in der Xbox oder Playstation, das hat da nichts mit Mac zu tun und für die ist das jetzt auch uninteressant und das ist jetzt wirklich nur die PC-Zockerecke, die ist natürlich auch riesengroß, aber der Konsolenmarkt ist halt auch riesengroß und die haben jetzt davon gar nichts, wenn Valve auf Mac kommt, aber für die PC-Zocker ist es auf jeden Fall ein cooles, ein kleines Highlight. Also ich meine, gab ja schon so ein paar Publisher Blizzard und hier ID-Software und so, die ja immer Parallelreleases haben, aber es waren auch wirklich nur zwei oder drei, ne? Und wenn jetzt Valve dazu kommt, ja, mal schauen, ob da auch wirklich andere, also ich bin eher gespannt, ob da noch dann die anderen Publisher, also auf Windows, ist ja glaube ich eben EA, Ubisoft, was gibt es noch so? Also es sind schon ein paar, die da auf diesem Steam ihr Zeug machen und da bin ich eigentlich gespannt, ob die dann auch auf die Mac-Plattform kommen oder ob es jetzt wirklich nur bei den Valve Games bleibt.
Es bleibt spannend.
Zumindest für Zoxors.
Hier wurde gerade so ein Trailer, irgendwie YouTube-Trailer gepostet im Chat, aber das hat erst mal meinen Safari zerdickt hier. Aber egal, das müssen wir jetzt hier nicht einspielen. So, was ist noch passiert? Jetzt können wir ja mal ein bisschen aufs iPad kommen.
Sabbern.
Das kann ja noch nicht gesabbert werden, weil... Wir haben ja noch keins.
Wir haben noch keins. Dennis hat ja eins in der Hand, aber den haben wir leider zugegaffert.
Deswegen sagt er auch nix mehr.
Der hat uns heute einfach so derartig gestenkt, dass wir gesagt haben...
Der ist ja wohl eher enttäuscht, weil die Gründe, egal.
Leute, es gibt noch keine iPads. Lasst euch nichts vormachen. Es gibt ein paar, aber man muss schon... Steven Colbert oder wer war der andere, der noch ein iPad aus seiner Hose rausgeholt hat? Was war noch das zweite Product-Placement?
Keine Ahnung.
Nicht aus der Hose, aus der Jackentasche.
Ach so.
Was war das, die Grammy?
Ich dachte, das wäre regelrecht Oscar gewesen.
Nein, das war vorher.
Bei Oscar gab es eine Werbung.
Nein, es war Musik. Wem hat er das gezeigt? Hat er das unter die Nase gerieben. Du hast noch keins.
Ich glaube, es war Grammys. Ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall lassen sie sich schon einiges einfallen, um den Hype noch weiter auszubauen. Aber der ist ja auch schon ganz ordentlich. Wir haben uns ja schon mal ausführlich über das iPad unterhalten. Und ich muss auch sagen, im Nachgang bisher sind mir da auch noch nicht so sehr viele neue Gedanken dazu gekommen. Oder ist dir mittlerweile irgendwas passiert?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jemals erwähnt haben. Nachdem du immer die ganze Zeit geifert hast, war ja dieses, dass man den Screen locken kann. Also wenn man es dreht.
Jaja. Steve hat Mobile Max.
Steve hat Mobile Max. Und dafür haben sie einen Hardware-Button.
Ja, das ist aber auch sehr angemessen. Weil ich meine, das ist nochmal eine Kern-Basis- Funktionalität dieses Gerätes, dass es sich immer mit dreht. Und das dann auf so einen Button zu machen, ist natürlich extrem klug, weil du dann keine User-Interface-Interaction mehr brauchst. Und das wäre auch mal etwas für das nächste iPhone. Auf den Mute-Button würde ich jetzt nicht verzichten wollen, aber ich hätte jetzt auch nichts gegen noch so eine Screen-Rotate-Block-Tasse. Meinetwegen können sie das auch mit irgendeiner Geste machen, Fünfinger drehen oder so was, dass man es damit abschließt und aufschließt oder so. Und es gibt ja auch so dieses, bei manchen, hier Mobile-RSS zum Beispiel, ist so ein Programm, das ist so ein RSS-Rieder. Halt dein Witz noch für dich. Weißt du, wovon ich rede? Also wenn man das Teil dreht, dann taucht es in der Mitte auf, dann kann man das, also ich drehe den um, dann taucht so dieses typische Schloss mit Kreispfeil drumherum auf, und wenn du in dem Moment drauf tippst, dann ist es gelockt. Und wenn du dann irgendwie drehst, dann leuchtet das auch mal wieder auf. Also kann auch ein bisschen störend sein, aber sie haben zumindest das Problem gelöst und erkannt und auch ein sehr einfach zu verstehendes User-Interface dafür gemacht. Und sowas würde mir auch schon reichen. Es nervt einfach maßlos. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Und das haben sie jetzt per Hardware gelöst, was natürlich sehr interessant ist. Mir ist nur eine Sache eingefallen, wo wir uns das letzte Mal nicht drüber unterhalten haben, was wir weggelassen haben. Was aber durchaus tierenswürdig war, meiner Meinung nach, nämlich die Tatsache, dass Apple ja seinen eigenen Prozessor angekündigt hat. Beziehungsweise da einfach reingebaut hat. Der A4, der von Audi hergestellt wird.
Ist da jetzt irgendetwas bekannt über diesen Prozessor?
Ja, es sind ein paar Details bekannt geworden.
Wie viele Kerne?
Einen. Es handelt sich tatsächlich um einen Single-Core-Design. Es ist nämlich anders als ursprünglich vermutet, doch kein Cortex A9. Also das allerletzte Arm-Design, was es derzeit zum Lizensieren gibt. Sondern es ist wohl dann doch noch ein Cortex A8, der auch keine große Überraschung mit der aktuellen Generation von PowerVR, diesem 3D-Design-Bude, ist ein interessantes Phänomen, insofern, als dass sie ja selber gar keine Prozessoren bauen. Und auch PowerVR tut das auch nicht. Es ist auch sehr interessant, dass sie beide in England sitzen. Oder beziehungsweise in Britannien, ich weiß jetzt nicht.
Die können da keine Silikonen einfliegen.
Bitte? Aus dem Silicon Valley, oder was? Visitium heißt das nicht, Silikon. Silikon kriegst du keinen Prozessor gebaut. Der würde dir wahrscheinlich zu groß werden. Also er wäre schön durchsichtig, aber er würde die Hitze nicht so richtig aushalten. Wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, sie haben halt diesen Stein zusammengebaut. Und der ist wohl recht schnell. Ist mit einem Gigahertz getaktet. Das ist auch der ebenfalls Cortex A8 basierte, wie heißt der? Aber offensichtlich ist das Ding wohl noch ein Zackenfixer. Wie sie das jetzt erreicht haben und insbesondere, wie sie diese 10 Stunden Laufzeit, die sie ja proklamieren und wo sie ja auch auf öffentlich geäußerte Zweifel hin immer wieder genickt haben und gesagt haben, ja, wir meinen das wirklich und so weiter, stellt euch darauf ein, das wird passieren. Wie sie das halt hinbekommen haben. Da spielt der Prozessor natürlich keine unerhebliche Rolle, wenn auch vor allem der Bildschirm da eine große Rolle spielt. Also das Bemerkenswerte daran finde ich einfach, dass sie ihren eigenen Prozessor zusammenbauen, weil das ist halt, das machen nur sehr wenige. Was sie aber dabei machen, also sie nehmen ja ein Lizenzdesign, also sie lizenzieren sich einen Design, sprich, wie dieser Prozessor intern tatsächlich funktioniert, das ist weitgehend schon vorgeschrieben und das bauen sie halt drauf, aber sie kombinieren halt die ganzen Komponenten. Und letzten Endes bauen sie sich halt ein SoC, also ein System-on-a-Chip, der alles das enthält, was sie halt brauchen bzw. und das denke ich mal, ist so ein bisschen auch der Schlüssel zu der ganzen Geschichte, wo alles nicht drin ist, was sie nicht brauchen. Weil heute kannst du natürlich diverse armbasierte SoC-Lösungen kaufen, und so hat Apple das ja bisher auch gemacht im iPhone. Nur die sind halt für den allgemeinen Markt ausgelegt und haben alle möglichen Interfaces, die aber unter Umständen gar nicht zum Einsatz kommen. Also was braucht Apple? Apple braucht natürlich WLAN, Apple braucht Bluetooth, und sie haben unten irgendwie ihren Docking-Port, aber das war es dann halt auch schon. Und viele andere Schnittstellen, die jetzt in anderen Embedded-Systemen unter Umständen auch noch unterstützt werden müssen, können sie halt weglassen. Und dadurch, dass sie natürlich weglassen, lassen sie potenziell auch immer wieder was weg, was eben auch irgendwie noch Aufwand bedeutet. Platzbrauch, Strombrauch, Komplexität schafft, etc. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich vermute allerdings, dass auch dieser A4 in dem nächsten iPhone drin sein wird. Es sei denn, sie sind wirklich so diversifiziert, dass sie sagen, okay, naja, da haben wir nochmal andere Anforderungen. Jetzt bauen wir den A5 und den A6 und den A7. Würde mich aber ein bisschen überraschen. Weil sie jetzt natürlich auch einen Riesenvorteil davon haben, wenn sie nur einen Chip bauen für die komplette Serie.
Aber echt mal jetzt hier, wenn man überhaupt sowieso...
Ich habe immer Erlaubnis, hier auf dieses Outline zuzugreifen, bitte. Ach so, geht nicht, weil ich ausgelockt bin.
Da darf jeder drauf zugreifen.
Ja, lass uns doch mal über das neue iPhone sprechen, iPad und so. Wir müssen irgendwie der Zeit voraus sein, statt immer nur über das Geschehenen.
Aber mit dem iPad sind wir aber mit der Zeit noch voraus, weil es gibt ja noch kein iPad. Würdest du dir eins kaufen, Huckel?
Ich würde meiner Oma eins kaufen.
Ernsthaft?
Also ich würde mir auch eins kaufen. Nein, meine Oma hat keinen. Aber ich hätte gerne, dass Oma noch mal ein bisschen im Internet Wikipedia lesen kann und ein bisschen E-Mail von Enkeln. Also für Oma wäre das bestimmt toll und für zu Hause vielleicht auch. Aber für Oma hätte ich es gut.
Ich glaube, Oma produziert jetzt nicht so viel. Ich würde dir das mal... Mach mal, wo ist Oma hinten in die Wolke?
Oma ist in die Wolke gegangen.
Oder bei Apple.
Das ist ja die Religionskriege der Zukunft. Das muss es eigentlich heute schon sein.
Also wenn, dann würde ich es einrichten, mir einmal so ein Backup-Image ziehen und dann ist es gut.
Ja, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass das iPad keine Wellenschläge, die derzeit durchaus Hall erzeugen. Zum Beispiel ist ja die ganze Debatte, was denn nun, wie denn das nun mit dem Video und den Webseiten ist. Jetzt hat man das erste Mal so ein Device, das eine vollständige Webseite anzeigen kann, vergleichbar zum Desktop-Rechner. Und es gibt halt kein Flash. Die Debatte haben wir hier auch schon ausführlich ausgerollt. Und das hatte sich auch neulich im Medienradio nochmal ganz ausführlich ausgerollt. Wer das nachhören möchte, Medienradio, letzte Ausgabe, drei Stunden Quaslei, nicht nur um Flash, aber in diesen ganzen Klimmbim. Trotzdem gibt es jetzt die ersten Ankündigungen von Webseitenbetreiber, dass sie eben iPad-kompatible Webseiten bauen werden. Sprich, sie werden in dem Moment, wo ein iPad darauf zugreift, tatsächlich dann auf HTML5-Video gehen. Und damit ist natürlich das iPad der Wegbereiter für einen Wechsel in der Mediendarstellung im Web. So, was sich über kurz oder lang dann eben auch wahrscheinlich auf moderne Browser umsetzen lässt.
Da gibt es hier übrigens auch so eine interessante These zu diesem ganzen Okteora H264 Lizenz-Fobar-Battle. Dass das auch dazu führt, dass dieses Okteora zunehmend an Bedeutung verlieren wird, weil wenn die Leute halt sozusagen keinen wenn der Firefox sozusagen nach wie vor kein H264 unterstützt, dann werden die Leute halt für Firefox-User sozusagen das H264 über ein Flash-Player ausliefern und ansonsten einfach HTML für ein Video, weil dann brauchen sie das Video nicht zweimal in Koden und zweimal auf der Platte liegen lassen, sondern sie haben ein H.264-Video und entweder der Browser kann es nativ oder über Flash. Oder über Flash, genau. So dass irgendwie einfach so ein kleiner Shortcut ist, wenn sie jetzt wirklich darauf beharren, Okteora und so zu benutzen, dass das dann auch keine Rolle spielt.
Okteora wird an Bedeutung verlieren. Ich muss überhaupt erstmal an Bedeutung gewinnen.
Naja, ich meine jetzt so in der Diskussion vor allen Dingen, in der Realität.
Das stimmt schon. Für Firefox ist das irgendwie ein echtes Problem, weil das Argument so mit wir sind ja irgendwie ganz frei stimmt halt an der Stelle. Also es stimmt, aber es ist natürlich insofern ein Schuss in den Rücken und sie dann Flash brauchen, um überhaupt dran teilzunehmen am richtigen Web. Ja, es ist wirklich eine lästige Debatte. Und ich kann ja da auch die FSF und sonstige, diese XIF Foundation, ich kann sie irgendwie schon verstehen, aber es ist wirklich ein bisschen unklar, wie es da weitergehen soll. Also in der Patentdebatte gibt es natürlich diesen FUD-War, dass diese mp4 LA sagt, es gibt Leute, die der Meinung sind, es gäbe da Patente. Wo XIF kontert mit, naja, wir legen euch seit zehn Jahren jetzt hier irgendwie schon alles vor, was wir hier implementiert haben, und ihr hättet euch ja mal äußern können. Dann gab es ja immer schon diese Vermutung, dass es ja nur einen großen Player braucht, der das mal zum Einsatz bringt, und dann werden sie dann irgendwie verklagt werden. Und diesen großen Player gibt es natürlich jetzt auch mit Google. Trotzdem scheint irgendwie so recht noch keiner wirklich mit einer Klage daher gegangen zu sein. Also ich weiß es auch nicht. Andererseits, es zeichnet sich einfach überhaupt nicht auch nur im Geringsten ab, dass Org Theora in irgendeiner Form Traktionen bekommt. Ja gut, die Wikipedia hat das.
Aber das Kommentar dazu war auch geil von Groover. Aber ich hab mir ehrlich gesagt noch nie ein Video in der Wikipedia angeguckt.
Nee, aber ich hab mir schon Bilder in der Wikipedia angeschaut und das wird sicherlich auch irgendwann mal stattfinden. Aber es wäre halt schon sehr viel einfacher, wenn die da auch als EPEC-4 H264 vorliegen würden. Themenliste. Dieser Tezart-Jailbreak. Es wird Porno geben auf dem iPad. Zumindest hat Apple jetzt eine Explicit-Kategorie eingeführt. War das im App Store?
Wann denn?
Ist jetzt so durchge...
Dass er das fürs iPad machen wollen.
Haben sie das schon?
Angekündigt ist ja gar nichts. Seit gestern tauchen massenhaft Screenshots aus dem iPad-Store auf. Wo dann auch die ersten Programme getestet werden. Es gibt ja offensichtlich schon Leute, die schon eins haben. So ein iPad. Die machen da fleißig Screenshots von. Und da gibt es wohl auch die Explicit-Kategorie. Im iPad-Store.
Was ist denn der iPad-Store?
Naja, quasi der App-Store-Bereich, wo es iPad-Apps gibt. Dieses Thinklinkr ist aber total scheiße.
Was bedeutet denn das denn? Ich meine Explicit. Warte mal, was steht denn hier? Ach so, da gibt es diese ganzen Movie-Ratings mit irgendwie GPG, PG-13, tralala. Und naja, die Frage ist, was ist denn da drin? Also was wird dann für zugelassen werden? Explicit iPad-Software. Also ist das dann Porn? Wollen sie jetzt doch Titten-Apps zulassen?
Nee, wollen sie nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht Porn, also Video?
Nicht. Wäre ein Riesenmarkt.
Stimmt.
So eine Porn-App, die irgendwie so ranking on demand, da ist definitiv Nachfrage.
Dafür ist auch dieses Lock-Feature wichtig.
Und das iPad ist einfach optimal. Das Glas-Oberfläche, das kriegst du irgendwie gut gereinigt. Das ist auf jeden Fall das optimale Teil. Also ich weiß nicht, wie weit sie da gehen wollen, aber ich würde mich in gewisser Hinsicht freuen. Nicht wegen des Eigenkonsums. Das kann man auch mit einem Web-Browser machen. Aber es wäre halt einfach auch eine Öffnung im Kopf, dass sie sich dem nicht mehr vollständig versperren. Ich meine, auch Bild muss ja auch irgendwie seine Inhalte unter Volkskrieg, vielleicht ist ja Bild-Zeitung demnächst dann unter Explicit. Da geht es ja nur darum, dass irgendwie The Sun...
Um deutsche Presseprodukte zu uns ersten Zugriff.
Ich meine, das ist doch das erste Mal, wo sich die deutschen Publizierer wirklich um Freiheit Gedanken gemacht haben. Wo sie dann irgendwie, dass sie ihre scheiß Tittenseiten nicht mehr publiziert bekommen.
Das ist irgendwie die Art von Freiheit, die sie interessiert haben. Weil das halt der erste Punkt war, wo sie Probleme bekommen haben. Ich glaube, hätten sie jetzt nicht mehr über Merkel berichten dürfen, dann hätten sie da auch einen kleinen Aufstand gemacht.
Verlogene Bande ist das. Verlogene Bande.
Twitter mal gerade noch meinen Witz, den ich gerade runterschlucken musste. Also wenn er wissen wollte, warum ich vorhin gelacht habe.
Ja, ich will wissen, warum du vorhin gelacht hast.
Da weißt du, du hast da mit so Touchgestures angefangen, hast da irgendwie rumgestikuliert und ich habe kürzlich Killbild mal wieder gesehen. Und da gibt es ja die 5 Pressure Points im Endkampf.
Das wäre eine geile Reset-Kombination fürs iPad.
Sie kämpfen ja dann kurz so zum Schluss und dann, so hier, zack, und dann kommt er und dann, zack, zack, zack, zack und dann, und dann darfst du noch 5 Schritte gehen und dann fällt sie tot um. Die 5 Pressure Points.
Also sie ballert ihm dann so aus Herz.
Ja, aber halt so an 5 Punkten und so. Und es sah irgendwie bei dir ganz genauso aus, als du gerade so in deinem imaginären iPhone irgendwie so da rumgetouched hast und das GreenLog mit so Special Gesture, die Kill Bill 5 Pressure Points.
Als Reset-Taste wäre das super.
Kill Bill, ja, wenn man das auf dem iPad macht, fällt Bill Gates.
Geohot hat einen J-Break fürs iPhone vorgestellt. Un-Tazard. Und für ein iPod...
Jetzt nochmal.
Geohot, der Typ, der schon diverse Male der umtriebige iPhone-Jailbreaker, den ja damals das Dev-Team rausgeschmissen hat, weil er ja irgendwie was gemacht hat. Was war das eigentlich? Ich weiß es nicht mehr so genau. Und der ja dann auch diverse Jailbreak-Lösungen schon vorgestellt hat. Der hat gestern ein Video gezeigt, wie er einen iPod-Taz der dritten Generation, das ist ja aktuell die dritte, ja, wie er den mit Jailbreak neu startet, einfach so, was ja bisher nicht ging. Also bisher war das ja so...
Ach so, dass nach dem Neustart das wieder weg war?
Genau, war es immer weg. Und er hat also den iPod gehackt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, auch diese iPhone 3GS, die nicht mehr, also die spätere Generation, die nicht mehr aufmachbar war. Und jetzt gehen natürlich alle davon aus, dass Apple wahrscheinlich genau die gleiche Technik auch noch am iPad einsetzen wird. Das heißt, mit ein bisschen Glück ist das iPad von Anfang an jailbreakable.
Ja, das bewegen wir uns ja mal wieder an diesem schönen Markt der Ideen, ne? Also das werden wir sehen.
Ja klar, aber er hat auf jeden Fall offensichtlich einen jailbreak gebastelt.
Also ob das iPad jetzt wirklich auf iPod Touch 3G-Technologie basiert, da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Naja, ich nehme mal an, dass sie den selben Bootstrap-Mechanismus drin haben und dass die Sicherheitslücke, die er da gefunden hat, dass die dann auch wahrscheinlich in den anderen Geräten drin ist.
Das ist eine Annahme, aber ich kann mir sehr wohl vorstellen, dass sie insbesondere diesen Bootstrap-Mechanismus weiter zuziehen, weil sie genau wissen, dass das das primäre Einfallstor ist.
Ja, aber die kannten sie jetzt ja noch nicht. Bisher dachten sie ja, also bis vorgestern war ja der iPod Touch total sicher. Ja gut, insofern warum was anfassen, was sicher ist.
Gut, kann sein, werden wir sehen.
Ja, werden wir sehen, bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es ja ein bisschen ruhiger geworden um Jailbreaks und ich würde gerne mal mein iPhone wieder jailbreaken.
Ich würde gerne mein iPhone mal wieder tetheren. Ich habe nämlich irgendwas Dummes getan. Nein, nicht, dass ich auch irgendwie mal Zeit hätte, mich mal in Ruhe drum zu kümmern, aber ich habe mir irgendwie mich meines Tetherings entledigt auf meinem Italo-Phone und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht warum. Also ich habe das jetzt hier irgendwie auch schon ein Network-Reset gemacht und Pi-Pa-Po und alle Profile rausgeschmissen und neu installiert und so weiter und es kommt einfach nicht wieder.
Telekom-Symp-Karte? Mit einer Telekom-Symp-Karte gibt es ja nicht.
Nein, nein, das ist Italo-Phone mit O2 und nachdem ich ja mein iPhone aktualisiert hatte auf 3.1.3, ging das ja dann da auch. Also ich habe vorher nicht aktualisiert, weil ich wusste, dass es danach nur noch nach Gesigned-Zertifikaten fragt. Aber ich kriege einfach dieses Feature nicht mehr eingeschaltet. Also ich kann dieses Zertifikat installieren, aber es bewirkt irgendwie gar nichts. Mir ist gerade völlig unklar, wie ich das wieder reaktiviert bekomme. Sprich, so richtig einfach machen sie es einem irgendwie immer noch nicht. Und das finde ich eigentlich immer noch eine Frechheit. Ich meine es schon mal gut, dass sie es jetzt nicht mehr so total verbieten und eine Tür offen haben, aber irgendwie renne ich die ganze Zeit gegen den Türrahmen, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Also bei mir funktioniert es einfach frei.
Ja, das ist schön. Aber lasst dir einfach gesagt sein, auf diesem iPhone-Computer kommt einfach diese Option nicht mehr hoch. Ich würde gerne mal wissen, wer jetzt konkret in dieser Kombination Italien-Phone plus O2 mit welchem Weg und genau mit welchen Profilen und Provider-Settings genau diesen Effekt hinbekommt. Nämlich erstens, dass das Telefon das O2-Netzwerk kennt. Also geht es nicht so sehr um das Logo da oben, sondern eher um diesen blöden Dialog, das er immer nicht zeigt mit dem Vorfallverbot.
Das habe ich leider auch.
Das wollte ich halt ausschalten. Ich habe mir halt diese Provider-IPCC installiert und danach ging es hier irgendwie nicht mehr, was ich nicht verstanden habe, was damit eigentlich nichts zu tun hat. Und danach habe ich die auch alle deinstalliert und wieder neu installiert und hin und her. Ich habe natürlich diese Profile, die bei BenAT und iPhone Notes, das sind ja so eigentlich die populärsten Anlaufstellen für O2. Ja, jeweils hab ich dann halt diese Profile genommen und damit hab ich es irgendwie nicht hinbekommen. Also vielleicht mach ich gerade irgendwas falsch oder resette irgendwie das Falsche. Mir ist es auf jeden Fall ein Ritz. Das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht habe, ist, dass ich einen kompletten Restore mache von meinem Telefon. Wobei ich mir auch irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen kann, dass es hilft.
Weil es dauert dann immer so lange.
Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es hilft.
Genau, das machen müssen auch bei sich, damit es wieder ging.
Nee, bei dem war irgendwas... Nee, der wusste einfach nicht, dass man noch mal die Profile runterladen kann.
Ich glaube, er wusste das schon, hat das auch gemacht, aber irgendwie hat es bei ihm auch erst nach so einem...
Nee, er wusste das schlicht und ergreifend nicht. Das weiß ich noch, dass er irgendwie so erzählt hat, wie er es dann hingekriegt hat.
Nein, nein, nein, das bleibt jetzt drauf.
Sonst ist da jetzt auch die ganzen Gummibärchen weg.
Ach so, by the way, wollt ihr noch ein bisschen... Ach nee, wir sollen ja nicht schmatzen.
Ich finde, wir können noch hier bei Opera Mini so ein bisschen...
Opera Mini, ach ja, du bist ja immer für diese Nischenthemen ein bisschen immer zu haben.
Diese Nischenthemen, die haben die, ich habe es auf Android ausprobiert.
Also Opera Mini ist dieser bekloppte Webbrowser, der die Webseiten bei Opera in Schweden rendert, wodurch sie Fallscherer freundlich werden. Ich mache Witze. Also sie rendern für dich und schicken dir dann nur noch ein PNG. Das soll dann schneller sein.
Nein, man kriegt kein PNG, man kriegt also Bytecode. Also das ist kompaktes HTML. Das ist ja schon Dex, was du da kriegst.
Ah, also er rendert schon was.
Ja klar, er rendert was. Es ist halt kein komplettes HTML mehr.
Ja.
Es wird so JavaScripte, die es nicht kann, werden rausgefiltert. Die Bilder werden halt zurecht optimiert in der Größe, dass sie hinhauen für diese Auflösung.
Also du entfädigst die Webseiten des JavaScripts.
Nein, wie gesagt, da passieren diverse Schritte. Also es wird komprimiert, das ganze Zeug. Der HTML-Code wird in einen Bytecode übersetzt, den ich jetzt natürlich auch nicht so genau kenne. Die Bilder werden runtergerechnet. Es passiert eine ganze Menge. Also sie haben oben, die haben bei sich, haben sie irgendwie dann einen Browser, der rechnet das Ganze, die Seite für dich vor. Und du kriegst sie dann ausgeliefert. Nicht als PNG, sondern als neues Opera-internes Format, was ein bisschen kompakter ist oder deutlich kompakter und wesentlich mobilfreundlicher. Das Ergebnis ist, wenn du eine Seite aufrufst, dauert es am Anfang länger, wenn er in Schweden rennt. Und dann, sobald er anfängt zu laden, geht es ratzfatz. Und zwar wirklich schön schnell.
Wo hast du denn das ausprobiert?
Ich hab ja auf dem Android-Telefon. Auf dem HTC Magic, da gibt es das. Also, ich meine, Opera Mini ist jetzt keine Neuigkeit. Das gibt es ja schon seit Jahren. Die aktuelle Version ist jetzt fünf. Ich hab das früher damals auf meinem K750. Das war das Einzige, womit man Hytix auch bar surfen konnte.
Aber die können nicht in der Lage, JavaScript auch noch mit zu berücksichtigen.
Der kann so ein bisschen JavaScript. Ja, die erweitern auch schon. Ich bin am Augenblick auch jetzt... Ich hab mich auch lange nicht mehr mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Eine Zeit lang war es so, dass es so On-Click-Events und so was hatten. Aber du konntest halt keine Background-Timer setzen oder so was. Wahrscheinlich ist das für die VM einfach zu eingeschränkt, die sie dabei haben. Und es ist ja auch noch das Prinzip, also eigentlich ist es ja wirklich so gedacht für das kleine dumme Telefon, wo es dann so ein Java zurechtgeschrieben ist. Und jetzt haben sie das Ganze auch fürs iPhone geschrieben und haben das mit viel Tamtam beim App Store eingereicht in den Approval-Prozess. Wahrscheinlich, falls sie abgelehnt werden, die entsprechend laute Meldung auch dann noch mal rauszupumpen, beziehungsweise wenn das jetzt in der Versenkung verschwindet. Was ich sehr schade finden würde, weil es ist halt, wenn man so wie ich viel mit der U-Bahn fährt und da immer nur Edge hat, dann macht es einfach keinen Spaß, da irgendwelche Seiten zu laden, weil das dann irgendwie zwei bis zur nächsten Station dauert, bis die Seite geladen ist. Und das würde mit Open-Mini definitiv schneller gehen. Also das Ganze profitiert von dünnen Telefonen, das ist das iPhone nicht, also von langsamem Telefon, aber auch von langsamen Geschwindigkeiten. Und wer schon mal in Brandenburg unterwegs war oder eben in der Berliner U-Bahn, der weiß, warum die alle dazu Nazis werden in Brandenburg, weil sie kein schnelles Internet haben. Und das könnte sich mit Open-Mini erlangen.
Alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewinn.
Neue Gesellschaftspolitik-These.
Sei mal, im Sommer am Baggersee irgendwo in Brandenburg, da wäre ich auch aggressiv, wenn ich das probiere zu surfen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall sei an der Stelle noch mal erwähnt, dass HTTPS-Traffic dann auch so ein bisschen pointless ist. Und ich glaube, es geht auch gar nicht.
Ich glaube, sie bieten HTTPS an. Man muss dann halt noch hofer Vertrauen unterwegs.
Ich habe da einfach nicht die Spur des Vertrauens, dass es sich dabei um einen Browser handelt, der mit dem Web mithalten kann. Also der einfach...
Doch, ist er...
.müssen alles nachbilden.
Das ist ein bisschen guter Browser. Das ist schon, das kann man machen. Das ist jetzt kein Webkit, der kann keine CSS-Animation, gar keine Frage, aber es ist so, wenn du Spiegel online lesen willst, ist das je darauf super.
Also die Frage ist ja eigentlich, wird es auf dem iPhone rauskommen oder nicht? Schwer zu beantworten.
Und es gibt viele Situationen, da könnte ich das Ding echt brauchen.
Ich sage, wenn das Ding so funktioniert, wie du sagst, dann werden sie es nicht zulassen.
Ich glaube, die haben überhaupt gar kein Problem, wenn da irgendwo ein Proxy rumsteht oder so was. Dann ist es einfach wie an einer Webbrowser, der nicht festgibt.
Da spricht einfach dem den STK-Bedingungen. Interpretiert seinen eigenen Bytecode, ist eigentlich genau das, was sie nicht wollen. Aber keine Ahnung. Wir werden es sehen. Selbst wenn es rauskommt, wird es auch keine besonderen Wellen schlagen. Ich habe auch gelesen, dass es jetzt vom Speed her, wenn du eine innschnelle Verbindung hast, keinen nennenswerten Unterschied macht. Also wenn du irgendwie 3G hast oder WLAN, dann ist das Ding eher noch langsamer, weil es erstmal den Umweg gehen muss.
Also auf diesem Android-Gerät war es extrem schnell auch über WLAN. Also der ist nun nicht so schnell wie der iPhone-Browser auf dieser Chrome unter Android. Aber da war es ein deutlicher Vorteil gegenüber diesem eingebauten Browser. Das war einfach auch über WLAN viel, viel schneller. Und das hängt sicherlich immer davon ab. Aber wenn ich mal eine langsame Verbindung habe, im Ausland bin, dann hätte ich gerne die Alternative.
Was meinst du in Brandenburg?
In Brandenburg, im Ausland oder in anderen unbewohnbaren Regionen. Nein, und sie können auch mehrere Tabs parallel laden. Guck dir mal dieses Video an. So surft es sich tatsächlich mit dem Ding. Kann man schon mal machen. So, jetzt noch andere abwegige Browser, Internet Explorer 9, wo wir schon mal dabei sind. Boring. Ich habe den mal ausprobiert.
Den gibt es schon?
Nein, den gibt es nicht. Es gibt ein Preview. Es gibt schon ein Code. Es gibt Code.
Und wie viele Jahre soll er rauskommen?
Ich glaube noch diese 100. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wann er rauskommen soll. Auf jeden Fall haben sie fett viel vorgestellt, was damit jetzt alles gehen soll. Und jetzt können wir auch CSS3 nur vier Jahre nachdem es alle anderen können und so ein bisschen HTML5. Und ich habe es mir angeguckt und bin damit ein bisschen... Es gibt ein paar Features, die sind echt okay. Also diese, was sie haben, sie haben halt so ein Demo, wo sie in so eine Karte rein- und rauszoomen in einer unglaublichen Geschwindigkeit. Also so wie man es so aus Filmen manchmal kennt, wo man dann so irgendwie aus einem Punkt auf der Erde sieht und dann so rauszoomt.
Das machen die dann mit Silverlight.
Das ist Bing Maps.
Dieses Bing Maps-Zoll quasi, das geht wirklich viel viel schneller als im Firefox oder im Chrome oder so was.
Aber wenn du dir das Silverlight installierst, na dann geht das ja auch alles total schnell.
Das Silverlight ist ja total super.
Ja, ich hab mir das installiert. Ja, ehrlich. Ich wollte halt, nachdem sie hier diese Bing Maps-Demo da gezeigt haben, wollte ich das jetzt auch mal ausprobieren, hab mir mal das Silverlight installiert.
Was kann man denn damit machen? Ich meine, dann hast du sozusagen deine Maps in Flash da, oder so.
Ja, nee, also du gehst halt auf mapsbingdingsbombs.de, was auch immer. Und dann gibt's halt so einen Button, irgendwie jetzt hier noch besser, noch toller, höher, breiter, schneller. Und wenn du das Silverlight installiert hast, dann irgendwie ist halt alles so, wie in dieser Demo. Also dann kannst du halt auch in Seattle und wo sie da diese tollen Picture auf 3D-Umgebung, Geschichten, kannst du alles schon ausprobieren und so. Das fetzt total.
Das heißt, das machen sie nur in Silverlight? Das machen sie überhaupt gar nicht im Web?
Und dann geht das auch am Mac?
Das geht auch am Mac und ich muss auch sagen, Silverlight zu installieren war echt um einiges angenehmer als Flash oder so. Also es ist schneller und legt sich auch nicht so. Also irgendwie, ich hatte ja auch echt Bedenken.
Ich hab so zweimal, Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Zweimal hab ich schon Silverlight abgebrochen zum installieren, aber dann, wenn ein drittes Mal da, ach jetzt machst du einfach mal.
Ah, haben sie dich gekriegt.
Ja, ich find ja Google.
Und danach musst du nur aufs Start-Menü unten links klicken.
Ich find ja, ach weiss nicht, ich find ja Google nie so doll gerade. So auch hier letztens Google Earth installieren. Jetzt musst du diesen scheiß Software-Updater installieren, von dem der im Hintergrund läuft und da alle deine Google Apps aktualisiert. Und so, ich hab da einfach gar keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, gibst du mal hier Bing eine Chance und guckst, wenn was da so geht.
Kann man den nicht eigentlich ausschalten, diesen Software-Updater?
Du kannst diesen, die machen dir halt einen Launch-Eintrag in deine User-Library. Das heißt, du kannst diesen Launch-Eintrag wieder rausschmeißen. Aber du darfst nicht die Software löschen. Das ist eigentlich voll fies. Ich dachte mir, okay, lässt er jetzt mal installieren, lösche ich dann wieder runter. Und dann installierst du dir die nächste Google App und dann sagt er, ja, aber hier in deinem Directory ist aber irgendwie gar nicht die Software drin. Sollen wir die mal installieren? Und dann will er die echt neu installieren. Ich dachte mir, ist scheißegal, ob dieser Launch, die man noch läuft, aber die Software, da checkt er halt, ob die da in dem Verzeichnis liegt. So und da dachte ich mir auch echt, ey Jungs, muss das denn sein?
Habt ihr dieses YouTube-Video gesehen, apropos Bing, von dem Typen, der von Steve Baumer gefeiert worden ist? Die saßen irgendwie in einem Meeting und dann hat Steve Baumer so zu allen irgendwie so, sag mal Bing, Bing, das klingt viel besser als Google, weil Google hat zwei Sillen und Bing hat nur eine. Bing, Bing, Bing, du sag Bing und dann so Bing, du sag Bing, Bing und dann beim Dritten so Bing, du musst das euphorischer sagen, bist gefeuert. Und er ist dann wirklich in Tränen ausgebrochen, weil halt irgendwie, das war noch vor Weihnachten, so kurz vor Weihnachten, mal ihn so gefeuert, weil er Bing nicht euphorisch genug gesagt hat, aber das interessiert dann keinen mehr.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich bestätigt, dass das kein Hoax ist, die Story? Ich meine, das wirkte sehr echt, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, wer soll es bestätigen, Sofsof?
Na, eine weitere Person, die dabei war zum Beispiel, also was weiß ich... Die Frau? Ich hab die Story auch gesehen, dass das wirkte wie ein sehr authentisches Video, aber was nicht alles heutzutage schon wie ein authentisches Video wirkt. Ich bin hier gerade auf der Spur von dem Google-Software-Updater. Du hast ja gesagt, das ist ein Launch-D-Eintrag.
In deinem User-Launch-D?
Ja, ich guck nämlich gerade mal, und zwar ein Tool, was ich euch auch sehr empfehlen kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt ernsthaft sehr empfehlen kann, aber ich sehe auch gerade, es ist hier einen spürbaren Schritt weitergekommen seit ein paar Updates. Das ist nämlich Lingon.
Aber das gibt's doch gar nicht mehr, das ist doch jetzt Abandonware.
Lingon? Warum konnte ich das eben gerade noch... Was? Wie? Lingon?
Der hat doch gesagt, mach ich nicht mehr weiter.
Ernsthaft?
Also es geht noch auf Snow Leopard. Die letzte Version.
Ist Ende 2008 die letzte Version rausgekommen.
Voll schade. Weil das Konsoleninterface für Launch, die ist echt treudig.
Lingon war immer ganz gut.
Liegt auf SourceForge rum.
Friedhof der Open Source Projekte.
No longer in the ITF. Egal, aber es gibt es noch.
Gut war das auch nie, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber es war besser als mal noch 2 Jahre, das stimmt.
Das ist super, wenn man erstmal verstehen will, was Launch, die eigentlich tut. Der zeigt einem halt alles an, was sich hier so installiert hat. Ich habe da auch ehrlich gesagt schon lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Da kommt was zusammen.
Da schalte ich gleich mal ein paar aus hier.
Was ich noch kurz vom Internet Explorer sagen wollte, da hat jemand so einen CSS-Font gebastelt, hast du den gesehen? Du hast ihn bestimmt gesehen. So ein komplett aus CSS zusammengebauten Font, was ziemlich geil ist. Den habe ich mal im Internet Explorer 9 aufgemacht. Ich würde mal behaupten, exakt so aus, wie es im Internet Explorer 6 aussehen würde. Ich glaube, abgerundete Ecken gingen noch nicht, Transparenzen gingen sowieso nicht. Wir machen jetzt HTML5 und CSS3, mach erst mal CSS2 von ihm, bevor er mit so einem Scheiß-Trick anfängt.
Das Video ist ein Hoax von Schauspielstudenten.
Schade.
Wird im Chat kolportiert.
Welches Video, das mit dem Bing? Aha, also doch.
Genau, Curtis hieß das.
Interessant, was sich hier alles so installiert, in diesem Launch-D. Aber mein Crashplan hat sich hier auch schon reingeworfen. Soweit hatte ich ihn schon installiert. Guck an. Vielleicht sind das schon die ersten Backups irgendwo in Text hast.
Genau, Curtis hieß dieser CSS-Font, der ist ziemlich geil.
Aber der User, den Google, den finde ich hier nicht.
Also ich habe den hier bei My Agents ganz oben. Come Google Keystone Agent.
Ich nicht.
Vielleicht hat er noch lange kein Update mehr gemacht.
Dann hast du dich noch davor zur Wehr setzen können, aber bei Google Earth konnte man sich nicht mehr wehren. Das war ganz schön scheiße. Die allerneueste, neueste Version. Also ich habe es mir halt frisch runtergeladen. Also nicht in Up Updates.
Gibt es gar nicht bei Google Earth. Man muss sich das immer runterladen.
Außer man hat den Google-Update.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass ich den irgendwann mal so von Hand entfernt habe. Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher.
Die Hand noch aber irgendwann mal hat doch Google vorgestellt, so ein Toolkit fürs Aktualisieren, fürs In-App-Aktualisieren.
Also mit dieser Sendung kriege ich keine Kapitelmarken hin. Das kann ich gleich sagen.
Also es ist mir total latte, muss ich sagen. Doch, aber selbst wenn ich irgendwie Podcast höre, also Kapitelmarken, also ich bin kein Profi Podcast-Hörer und so.
Da werden jetzt nicht alle Hörer mit dem Kopf schütteln. Nicht alle mit dem Kopf nicken, meine ich.
Ja, nee, nee, aber ich, also für mich... Ich finde das super.
Sorry für missigen Kapitelmarken.
Also für die diskordische Bibelstunde, da war das mit den Kapitelmarken ganz groß.
Auch beim Bundesradio ist das ganz toll.
Ja, also prinzipiell super, aber die Welt geht nicht unter.
So, wollen wir noch ein Thema aufmachen?
Doch, doch, doch, doch, die Welt geht unter.
Die Welt wird untergehen, und zwar wann? 2012.
Wenn Loss zu Ende ist.
So, wie viele Themen können wir anschneiden ohne eins? Nee, und die hatten noch irgendwann mal so einen Ersatz für Sparkle gebastelt mit diesem... Haben wir darüber mal gesprochen?
Wer hat was?
Google hat irgendwann mal so einen Update-Manager geschrieben. Wahrscheinlich wird er auch in diesem Software-Update-Manager geschrieben, mit dem sie ein bisschen kompaktere Updates hinbekommen haben auf dem Mac und auch so Kommando-Zahlen-Programme aktualisieren lassen konnten. Und ich glaube noch Bibliotheken, während sie laufen, oder irgendwie so ein Spaß.
Das ist doch dieser Google-Software-Update da.
Nee, sie haben das als Open-Source-Projekt.
Achso, achso, achso, achso. Sie sind nämlich sanft. Und was ist damit?
Viel mehr ist bloß gerade in dem Zusammenhang ein, das war nicht drüber.
Damit du mal mit deinen Kapitelmarken noch ein bisschen...
Wie das Internet ist weg?
Suche nach dem PPPoE-Host.
Ich hab hier Internet, alles super. Ja...
Darauf wollte ich die ganze Zeit hinaus. Wir haben eigentlich jetzt gar keine Themen mehr. Also zumindest finde ich jetzt gerade... Nein, also... Alle Themen, die jetzt in der Liste sind, finde ich wenig entweder ein bisschen langweilig oder beziehen sich auf Dennis. Abgesehen... Davon, dass man jetzt nochmal hier so unseren... unseren monatlichen Marktrand gibt uns heute Teil machen könnte. Also, ihr werdet ja mitbekommen haben, dass die Firma Palm gerade irgendwie sehr unleidlich wahrgenommen wird, also sie haben eine Gewinnwarnung rausgegeben und jetzt meinen alle Analysten, dass so der Aktienkurs tendenziell gegen Null geht und keiner weiß, was aus Palm wird. Die haben sich aber auch schon einige Schnitzer geleistet, muss man sagen. Also, das ist ja nun auch nicht wirklich so gut gelaufen da. Na, erstmal sind sie halt so mit Sprint gestartet zum relativ kleinen Provider in USA war es wohl so, dass sie irgendwie in den ganzen Läden einfach niemanden hatten, der sich mit diesen Telefonen auskennt. Also, dieses typische In-Store-Training haben sie einfach nicht in dem Maße beherzigt, wie es vielleicht ganz angemessen gewesen wäre. Wir erinnern uns, das ist ein Problem, was den Mac-Markt ewigkeitenlang geplagt hat, weil du gehst dann zu Kaufhof und dann steht da irgendwie auch ein Mac rum, aber keiner kann irgendwas dazu sagen, weil die alle nicht damit arbeiten und nichts wissen. Und das haben natürlich jetzt diese Retail-Stores bzw. diese, wie nennen sie das nochmal? In-Store Mac? In-Store, In-Store. Store in a Store-Konzept. Das hat halt dann doch schon eine ganze Menge geändert, weil du halt irgendwie Leute hattest, die eben auch wirklich Plan hatten oder zumindest halbwegs Plan hatten von den Produkten und dir da auch was dazu sagen können. Naja, das sind alles so Sachen, die nicht so gut funktioniert haben. Abgesehen davon, dass diese Hardware halt auch irgendwie Mist war. Meine Software, okay, aber so richtig gut lief es wohl auch nicht.
Naja, ich glaube Palms großes Problem ist, dass das eigentlich schon vorher Pleite waren.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Sie hatten kein Geld für die Größe der Sprünge, die nötig gewesen wäre, um, also ich würde jetzt um das so richtig geil machen. Und sie haben es auf Dreiviertelstrecke leider dann immer ein bisschen.
Ja, also macht auf jeden Fall gerade nichts von dem Eindruck, als ob sie jetzt zu den großen Containern gehören werden. Nokia, meine Lieblingsfirma, die ist ja auch super. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit diesem Community- based Phone-Design?
Nee, ich habe es ignoriert. Ich habe es ganz oft gesehen.
Die haben ernsthaft eine Webseite rausgebracht, wo sie dann so, ja, und jetzt könnt ihr hier irgendwie so mit Slidern sagen, ja, wenn ich ein Telefon haben wollte, dann müsste das irgendwie so großen Bildschirme haben und müsste diesen und jenes Feature aufweisen. Ich weiß nicht.
Das erinnert mich, kennt ihr diese Simpsons-Folge, in der Simpsons das Auto designt? Das Auto der Zukunft?
Ja, genau darauf wurde ja auch schon mehrfach verwiesen im Netz. Was ich persönlich daran wirklich ein bisschen arm finde, also erstens glaube ich nicht, dass sowas funktioniert. Das ist ja auch so etwas, was meiner Auffassung nach Apple extrem auszeichnet. Also Apple macht ja so ein paar Sachen nicht, die andere Firmen machen. Zum Beispiel hat Apple keine Berater und Apple macht keine Marktforschung. Und sie machen deshalb keine Marktforschung, weil sie der Meinung sind, dass die Leute sowieso nicht wissen, was sie in Zukunft benutzen wollen. Also sie wissen es halt einfach gar nicht. Sondern sie verstehen ihren Auftrag darin, für die anderen zu erdenken und zu erfühlen und zu spüren, was das nächste ist. Und ich muss auch sagen, mit solchen Befragungen habe ich auch so nur begrenzt Erfolg gemacht. Also da, wo ich mal versucht habe, mir Vorschläge machen zu lassen, zu etwas, worüber ich nachdenke, was man in Zukunft machen kann. Ich halte das jetzt mal ganz bewusst abstrakt, wenn ich nicht mit zu vielen Beispielen nerven. Aber ich habe immer wieder gemerkt, dass ich... Wie soll man das sagen? Das Feedback, was du bekommst, bewegt sich irgendwie immer im Realitätsraum des Ist-Zustandes. Also es gibt wirklich sehr, sehr wenige Leute, die dir wirklich so visionär an so eine Fragestellung rangehen, um dich in irgendeine Richtung zu zeigen, wo du eben auch dich bestätigt fühlen könntest.
Das ist eigentlich der Job des Fragestellers. Er sollte nicht andere Leute fragen, wie er es machen soll, sondern er sollte sich selber Gedanken ummachen.
Genau.
Und woher sollen die Leute das wissen? Sie sitzen nicht die ganze Zeit da und machen sich Gedanken darüber, wie man es besser machen kann, sondern sie können dir im besten Fall sagen, was sie an dem aktuellen Zustand scheiße finden. Obwohl die meisten können nicht mal das.
Ja, die wissen manchmal gar nicht, was sie nervt.
Ja, die wissen nicht mal, dass sie genervt sind.
Und deswegen denke ich einfach, dass Nokia auch mit diesem Schritt keine nennenswerte Änderung herbeiführen wird.
Was soll dabei wohl rauskommen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber ich meine ganz offensichtlich, also die Botschaft, die ich als erstes da rausgelesen habe, ist, wir wissen nicht, wie man ein Telefon bauen soll. Das ist einfach die einzige Nachricht, die bei mir angekommen ist, als sie dieses Community-Ding gelesen hat. Wir wissen auch nicht mal, wie groß das Ding sein soll, geschweige denn sonst wie. Es ist irgendwie alles... Wir haben einfach keine Ahnung, helft uns. Das nennen sie dann Community Designed Phone. Na ja, ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob da überhaupt noch mal irgendwas dabei rauskommt. Gibt es noch Vorschläge? Sonst können wir auch Schluss machen.
Also, ich will uns jetzt hier was aus der Nase ziehen.
Max? Habe ich noch irgendwas Konkretes? Ach ja, ich wollte neulich das quasi los... Das hätte ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Habt ihr schon SIM-Karten für eure iPads? Na ja, wenn wir uns demnächst iPad holen, dann brauchen wir auch passende SIM-Karten dafür, oder?
Wie viel kosten das eigentlich? Das haben sie immer noch nicht gesagt, ne?
Nee, nee, haben sie immer noch nicht gesagt.
Ich kann die überhaupt noch nicht beantworten, ob ich da ein iPad habe. Wie viel kostet das in Amerika?
Ich hab die SIM-Karte an dem Tag, wo ich ein iPad habe, hab ich eine SIM-Karte, weil dann nehm ich irgendwie eine Schere und schnitz mir das zusammen.
Ach, du machst das dann tatsächlich auf die Harte. Ich wollt jetzt einfach bei O2 eine bestellen, nicht?
Schnipp, schnipp, schnitz, schnitz. Na, die geben mir doch jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres noch ne...
Sind wir Nerds oder sind wir Nerds?...
noch ne weitere Karte, oder?
Natürlich, die zahlst du irgendwie 20 Euro und kriegst eine neue SIM-Karte.
Wie viele Multisims kriegt man denn?
Also ich hab bisher glaube ich 4 oder 5.
Gleichzeitig?
Ja, klar.
Echt?
Ja, ich hab, also ich hab, also ich hab einen iPhone, einen im Stick, ne drei hab ich bisher. Und eine in Android, die steckt im Augenblick richtig in der Hosen-Tasche stecken. Aber ich bin einfach noch ne Viertel, klar, warum nicht? Okay, das ist, also zwei sind im Preis inklusive und danach kostest du halt ein bisschen mehr. Musst halt ein bisschen Bearbeitungsgebühr zahlen.
20 Euro?
Ja, oder 25 oder irgendwie sowas.
Na dann hol ich mir noch eine so und schneid mir die zurecht. Aber du hast jetzt noch nicht gefragt, ob sie schon Mini-SIM anbieten.
Ich hab probiert, bin oft, hab mich eingeloggt bei O2 Online, bin dann draufgegangen, hab auf Support geklickt, hab so hier unseren Chat, ich dachte so, also ich meine entweder kann man eine Telefonnummer anrufen, wo man ewig in der Bartoschleife hängt, ich hatte ja gedacht so, lasst mich euch eine Mail schicken, so die ganz klassische Art, hab ich da in den Chat, hab da meine Frage reingehackt und dann stand da immer so die ganze Zeit so, vier Fragen müssen noch für euch beantwortet werden, vier Fragen müssen noch für euch und nach einer Weile kommt dann einfach so, kein Bock. Ja, hat zu lange gedauert, rufen sie doch einfach an. Hab ich auch gedacht, wofür macht ihr denn einen fucking Chat, wenn ich dann nach einer Weile einfach rausgeschmissen werde? Vor allen Dingen ist das auch nicht so, wir haben ihre Frage doch per Mail weitergeleitet oder so. Nö, die ist einfach weg. Ich habe mir da echt Mühe gegeben, da ausführlich eine Frage zu formulieren. Irgendwie haben die ganzen Telcos das doch noch nicht so richtig drauf mit diesem Support. Das Einzige, was wir da eigentlich machen, das haben wir nicht drauf.
Welch Wunder.
Ja, aber wie kann man jemand aus seinem Chat rausschmeißen? Sie wollen dich offensichtlich auf diese Telefonen. Wahrscheinlich haben die ein Deal mit der Telefonwarte Musikhersteller. Da könnte man eine schöne Verschierungstheorie zu entwickeln. Warum haben die nicht einen Schick-uns-einen-Mail-Button? Und wie beantworten wir das bis morgen?
Das ist auch hochgradig unseriös, finde ich das, wenn man da keine Mail schreiben kann. Eigentlich ist das immer ein total cooles Feature, mal eine Mail zu schreiben, weil man denkt sich ja so, wenn ich jetzt als kleiner User eine Mail schreibe und ein Feature-Request und so, das lesen die doch eh alle nicht und so weiter. Aber hier gerade so bei Steve Jobs, der hin und wieder mal Mails beantworten lässt oder so an, ich mache das ja immer, ich schreibe einfach immer eine Mail und oft kommt auch tatsächlich was zurück. Und wenn man dann gar nicht die Möglichkeit bekommt und dann nicht mal im Who-is-Rekord eine E-Mail-Adresse findet, an der man jetzt sein Leid klagen kann, das ist, das gefällt mir nicht. Ich hab letztens, wollte ich eine Band mir Musik kaufen und dann gab es die nur als MP3 oder als Schallplatte. Und da meinte ich ja, Jungs, wie sieht es denn aus? Könnt ihr nicht mal einen Flagg-Download auf BoomCat oder so anbieten und so? Und dann hat er in der Antwort sein ganzes Label mit inkludiert, also alle Leute, die an dem Label zu tun hatten. Und meinte hier in meiner Alnol... Ja, ich glaube nicht, wie seht ihr das Jungs? Und dann dachte ich mir, ah, Mensch, das ist ja super, wenn er hier gleich das ganze Label ins CC-Fail schreibt. Dann mach ich noch mal direkt Reply All. Und dann habt ihr noch mal in epischer Breite geschrieben, dass ich jetzt gerne noch mal lossless-Download hätte. Dann hat das Label gesagt, ne, machen wir aber nicht. Und dann hat mir der Typ privat noch mal zurückgeschrieben, meinte, ich kann dir eine CD brennen und schicken, ich hab die Masters. Hat er auch gemacht, so aus London, total geil. Und darum, so Mail schreiben muss schon sein, also...
Mail schreiben muss schon sein, ne?
So.
Jetzt haben wir uns alle ausreichend abgeregt. Und angeregt unterhalten. Und ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt hier mal den Call und sagen Tschüss.
Genau, immer jetzt den Five-Point-Pressure-Touch-Geste auf das Mischpult und...
Nicht bei Dennis!
Bis alles explodiert. Genau, so ist das, Leute. Und dann wird jetzt hier auch gleich das Stream abgeschaltet. Und dann war es mal wieder vorbei mit Mobamex. Und wir machen irgendwann auch wieder weiter. Mal gucken, ob wir wieder zu einem 2-Wochen-Rhythmus kommen. Aber wenn es so wenig Nachrichtennage gibt, dann können wir auch einfach mal länger Pause machen, oder?
Weil wir reden ja die ganze Zeit nur über aktuelle Nachrichten.
Nee, aber ich meine, es ist ja... Wir haben ja schon eigentlich zu allem unseren Sermon abgelassen. Aber es ist schön, dass wir zwischendurch auch mal wieder ein bisschen Erfahrungswerte einbauen können. Genau, gibt uns auch mal ein paar Tipps irgendwie zu guter Buchhaltungssoftware. Das finde ich mal einen interessanten Nachtrag. Ich bin da selber gerade so ein bisschen am Gucken, was man mal so verwenden könnte. Und vielleicht gibt es ja noch was Schönes.
Dennis nickt auch, dass er Tschüss sagt.
Nein, immer noch keine Gummibärchen.
Okay, dann sagen wir jetzt Tschüss und bis bald.